Nikhil: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between KFC in India and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in India, we have two
types of chicken sandwiches,
a Krisper and a Zinger.
In the US, we have two
chicken-sandwich options,
the Chicken Little, 'cause it's little,
and, of course, the Kentucky Fried Chicken
chicken sandwich. The classic.
Now let's weigh them to see
how much they weigh, obviously.
Ugh! This thing has not been cleaned
in a very long time.
Nikhil: All right, first
up, the chicken Krisper.
Joe: Our Chicken Little
in the US weighs ...
Next up, the chicken Zinger.
Joe: 240 grams for the
classic chicken sandwich.
This thing is a work of art.
All right, on to chicken popcorn.
Here in India, we have it in three sizes,
regular, medium, and large.
We're going to weigh our large popcorn
to see how much we get.
I actually really love chicken popcorn.
I have an idea. We should
weigh one popcorn chicken
and add that back to the total.
My bad, my bad.
They should serve this in movie theaters.
I don't want regular popcorn anymore.
Mm!
I love that they sprinkle
in a bunch of sesame seeds,
and it adds a nice crunch to it.
What? Sesame seeds? We don't have that.
All right. You guys are lucky.
That sounds really nice.
We only have one size
according to the website
and the KFC I went to, and that is this.
How accurate do these
measurements need to be, really?
Oh, it's so good!
Unfortunately, here in India,
we do not have mashed potatoes,
but that would be pretty awesome.
We do have fries. We're big fans of them.
And they come in two
sizes, medium and large.
And in the US, we also have
two sizes of fries at KFC,
the individual, for an individual,
and the large, also for an individual.
Nikhil: Let us now measure the large
to see how much you get.
140 grams.
[laughing]
That's never not funny.
That's the third time that's happened,
and it's always funny.
Look at that block of fries.
Our largest fry is more than
double their largest fry.
Here's our individual.
150!
Our smallest is bigger than their largest.
In KFC India, we can get our
chicken in six portion sizes.
No. 1, the single piece.
Two-piece.
They like to give you
one breast piece and one leg piece. Kind.
Four-piece. Leg piece to top it all off.
The leg piece on top, as they say.
Like cherry on top. No? OK.
Now we move on to buckets.
We have four sizes.
The first one is a five-piece bucket
that comes with only leg pieces
and also does not come in
a bucket for some reason.
Why, KFC? I want a bucket.
Next up, we have a six-piece bucket,
an eight-piece bucket,
and the largest one of them all,
a 10-piece leg bucket.
Whew, that's a lot of chicken.
In the US, our KFC chicken
comes in seven portion sizes.
One, which you can get à la carte;
two-piece, with a combo;
three-piece, with a combo;
four-piece, with a combo.
Then [snaps] buckets.
Did that work? OK.
We have an eight-piece.
Yeah, eight pieces.
The 12-piece.
And our largest bucket, the 16-piece.
Ready, Yuelei?
What?
You get the idea.
Next up, you're going to need a drink
to wash all that chicken down.
Here in India, we don't serve
cups, we just serve cans.
We have Pepsi; 7Up; Mirinda,
which is an orange soda;
Red Bull; and a Pepsi PET bottle.
However, these will vary
from store to store.
In some places, they
might not serve plastic,
and in some places, you
might not get these drinks,
you might get something else.
They also serve something
called a virgin mojito Krusher,
which they don't deliver, unfortunately,
but here's an image of it.
Refreshing.
American drinks come in
these following sizes:
the regular, which is 20 ounces,
and the large, which is 30 ounces.
And we don't stop there.
If you want, you can also get
half-a-gallon bag
of your favorite drink of choice.
Look at this thing!
Mm.
It's convenient.
[burps]
Here is everything you'll
find on the menu at KFC India
that you won't get in the US.
And here's everything you
can find at a KFC in the US
you won't find in India.
Take a look, India. Take a good look.
OK, let's start with chicken.
In India, apart from the crispy chicken,
we also get smoky red chicken.
Ooh.
Wow.
I believe this is KFC's
answer to tandoori chicken.
If you guys don't know what a tandoor is,
it's basically a cylindrical oven
that they light up using
wood fire or charcoal,
and it adds a really
smoky flavor to the meats
or breads that you cook inside of it.
I doubt KFCs across the
country have an actual tandoor,
but the flavoring
definitely smells like that.
The marinade looks like that.
Oh, my God, that's actually pretty good.
You know what, KFC?
Pretty good job.
You have to remember, KFC is competing
with a lot of Mughlai restaurants
across every Indian city,
and while this doesn't
have as much of that
smoky char that a lot
of tandoori kebabs have,
it has a lot of flavor,
and the chicken is quite juicy.
Good job.
It's super spicy though,
so if you're somebody
who can't handle spice,
go a little easy on this one.
When an Indian says
something's spicy, it's spicy.
I believe you, man. I believe you.
That looks incredible.
We, unfortunately,
don't really have anything
too spicy on the menu
for the chicken-on-the-bone options.
Really the only thing that we have here
that apparently you guys don't have
is something that is what I associate
Kentucky Fried Chicken
with, is extra-crispy.
I don't know exactly what
makes it extra-crispy,
but it is, as you can imagine,
crispier than the regular chicken.
[crunching]
Extra-crispy to me is far superior
to the regular way they cook chicken.
I think it should be the other way around.
This should be the regular,
and the other one should
be, like, half-crispy.
You know what I mean? This is way better.
All right, let's move on
to chicken sandwiches.
Here in India, we don't have
an American chicken sandwich,
but we have a Zinger
and a smaller sandwich
called a Krisper. Cute.
The Krisper looks like it wants to grow up
and be a Zinger someday.
They also come in two variants,
a spicy Krisper and a tandoori Zinger.
Let's taste all of them.
Oh, that's pretty yum.
They've used a different
kind of mayonnaise here.
It has a bit of sweetness to it
and a spicy kick at the end.
And now for the legendary Zinger.
Back in the day, there were only two
fast-food chains here in India,
it was McDonald's and KFC.
And while McDonald's had more
affordable burger options,
the KFC Zinger was so delicious,
it was always a treat to eat.
Mm. And it still is.
I love that they use a whole
boneless piece of proper chicken in there.
Delicious mayo.
It's so delicious.
OK, now let's try the spicy variants.
This is the spicy Krisper.
Look at this sauce!
It's almost blood-red. I'm excited.
Oh, my God.
This sauce almost has
a Szechuan taste to it.
Next up, the Zinger, but tandoori.
Mm. I love the fullness of the chicken
that comes in these burgers
versus, like, a minced chicken
patty in other restaurants.
There's so much bite to it.
It's so juicy, tender.
That all sounds amazing.
Stop, you're going too fast!
I have to say, those
sandwiches look delicious,
and I am jealous.
One sandwich you can get here in the US,
can't get in India,
is this little guy, the Chicken Little.
Looks to be a chicken tender
in between these tiny little buns.
Pickles, goodbye.
Could probably eat, like, five of those.
Slightly different from
what you have in India,
so I'm going to use it as an excuse
to show it off yet again.
Our crispy chicken sandwich.
This thing, the original, the bad boy.
Also with pickles.
Hang on.
Get off of my sandwich.
But it has this really creamy
mayo sauce on it, the bun.
I love this.
Yeah.
Other chicken stuff we
got here you ain't got.
I'm already getting loopy.
Start over here, Nashville
hot tender chicken.
Here, this, I think, is the spiciest thing
you're getting at the KFC menu.
And I'm gonna be straight
up, I've had these before,
these are pretty good.
And they're really crispy, Yuelei.
Want to hear that crisp again?
[crunching]
Not sure if it's made
it over to India yet.
It is called a chicken pot pie.
It's a pie, but instead
of there being, you know,
fruit or any of the sweet stuff you like,
they fill a pie with chicken,
and what do you think else is in here?
Corn, gravy, peas maybe.
I have no idea. I'm not
going to rip this thing open.
This thing, it's got some weight to it.
This is a meal right
here. This is not a side.
I don't know where it is
in the menu, but whew.
This right here, the KFC Famous Bowl.
And it is famous, let me tell you.
Nikhil, if you're wondering what this is,
someone at KFC was like,
"How can we put everything into one bowl?"
And this thing was born.
It is mashed potatoes, corn,
the popcorn chicken,
cheese, and gravy, all
in a convenient bowl
for you to eat while you are driving.
It generally does nothing for the flavor.
It's exactly what I would
think this would taste like.
It's just a bunch of
this stuff in one bowl.
Yes, in India, you can
get wings at the KFC,
but at our KFC in the US, you
can get your wings sauced.
And we have three different sauces,
honey barbecue, Buffalo, Nashville hot.
Honey barbecue, thumbs down.
This Buffalo's a lot more orange
than I recall Buffalo being.
I cannot quite place my finger
on why suddenly my stomach is killing me.
Do you see inside there?
OK.
[Yuelei laughs]
On to the next wing.
Bring on that food poisoning, baby.
Um, yeah, all these are bad.
All right, moving away from chicken,
India's KFC actually has
vegetarian alternatives
for all our burgers.
There is a vegetarian Krisper,
a vegetarian spicy Krisper,
and a vegetarian Zinger.
Now, while India has a majority population
of nonvegetarians, around 70%,
there is a huge vegetarian population,
which is why a lot of
fast-food restaurants
have to make sure they have
a lot of vegetarian options
on their menu to make it more approachable
and acceptable for all people over here.
There's also levels to
vegetarianism over here.
There are I-will-eat-egg-but-not-chicken
vegetarians.
There are I-will-eat-fish-but-not-lamb
There are I-will-eat-the-curry-
but-not-the-pieces vegetarians.
There are I-am-vegetarian-only-on-Tuesdays
vegetarians.
There are I-have-made-a-promise-to-God-
for-this-one-month vegetarians.
There are I-am-vegetarian-
so-you-will-all-be-vegetarian vegetarians.
They're the weird ones, and
we try not to talk about them.
Which is why KFC in India
brands itself as just KFC.
There's no Kentucky Fried
Chicken anywhere here
because, obviously,
I'm not going to go to a
place that's named that
if I'm one of these many
types of vegetarians.
One iconic dish that you'll
find on the KFC India menu
is biryani.
And so KFC India has
taken a very bold decision
to launch their own biryanis.
If you don't know what biryani is,
you are living under a
gigantic boulder, my friend.
Hey, guess I live under a boulder
because I, unfortunately, am
not familiar with biryani,
but I would love to know more about it.
Hello! I am Crystelle Pereira,
and I am a cook and a baker,
and you may know me as a finalist
from "The Great British Bake Off."
This [bell dings] is biryani.
Now, biryani is a typical rice
dish you find in South Asia,
and the way you make it is in layers.
My dad is a biryani master at home,
and the way he makes
it is with cooked rice,
cooked potatoes, some
fried onions, and a curry.
We like to go for a mutton biryani,
but you can get chicken or fish,
and in this case, vegetarian biryani.
We absolutely love it,
and we always eat it as a family unit
with a lovely pot of
cooling raita on the side,
which is a lovely cooling yogurt dish
which goes really well
with the spicy biryani.
And it's basically our
equivalent of a Sunday roast,
because you have it in a big
pot and you all take scoops.
And I actually don't think
I've ever eaten biryani
by myself for one person.
Now, we have to talk
about this KFC biryani,
because for me, biryani is a home dish.
You make it in a home kitchen,
it's cooked by a family member,
and it's cooked with love.
My first impression, a KFC biryani,
those two words just
don't go together for me.
Just to give you guys context
of what it's like to be Indian
and eat a biryani at KFC,
it's like being Italian and
eating a pasta at Domino's.
Got it, thank you.
Continue.
They come in four flavors.
No. 1, classic chicken, nice and crispy.
No. 2, popcorn chicken.
No. 3, the spicy red
chicken that I really enjoy.
And No. 4, the veg patty,
which, it's so tempting to
just push that to the side,
because veg biryani is already just
a concept that we're
not a fan of over here.
But just for now, you can stay here.
OK, I'm going to begin with
the popcorn chicken biryani,
which is just so
blasphemous to begin with.
Mm.
Hm.
It's not a biryani.
It's ...
I'm so upset right now.
This one, the spicy red chicken,
has a bit of that tandoori vibe to it.
They've really tried to
overcompensate with the spices.
There's a lot of clove flavor
just to convince you you're
eating a biryani, so,
go easy on that curry.
I could eat this, like, if I was hungry.
Not a biryani, though.
That biryani looks real
depressing. I am sorry.
But we do have these
exclusive side dishes,
which are mashed potatoes,
I can't believe you guys
don't have mashed potatoes.
It feels like this is flagship stuff here.
Macaroni and cheese.
Biscuits. Again, no biscuits?
Coleslaw.
This giant dish of just gravy,
and, of course, sweet corn.
New country, new sauces,
y'all know what that means.
Sauce talk.
First one, I mean, the KFC sauce.
Why this isn't at every KFC
internationally, I have no idea.
Get a load of that sauce right there.
I think it's, like, ketchup
and mayo, but it's really good.
Honey barbecue.
I know what that tastes like.
Honey mustard.
That's not your thing?
Honey.
And, of course, you got classic ranch.
Not much of a ranch aficionado,
but theirs is just OK.
And, oh, I forgot about
their hot sauce, Yuelei.
India does not have too
many exclusive dips.
In fact, we just have a
veg eggless mayonnaise
and a tandoori masala mayonnaise.
It's time to taste.
I'm using the same hand,
because here in India,
we don't eat with our left hand.
If you're wondering why,
commenters, you let them know.
"Why don't Indians
eat with their left hand?"
Well, it's just mayonnaise,
so good job on that.
Mayonnaise again,
with a little bit of a sweet
but also spicy kick to it.
I wish we had more options,
especially considering there are so many
different delicious chicken options.
I'd love to be able to dip
my tenders in more sauces.
That is a weird sentence.
For those of you with a sweet tooth,
we have two exclusive dessert options.
Chocolate chip cookie
and this chocolate chip cake.
How good does this look?
Here in India, we have
two exclusive desserts.
A choco mud pie and a coffee mousse cake.
Ooh, boy!
Just look at this cross
section, my friend.
Next up, coffee mousse cake.
Yeah,
these are pretty average as desserts.
Drinks, drinks,
drinks!
Maybe my favorite part of
the exclusives section.
Exclusive drinks you can get in the US
you cannot get in India.
Mountain Dew.
I'm back, baby. Mm.
And if you're a Mountain
Dew fan, such as me,
you know KFC has got the exclusive
Mountain Dew Sweet Lightning.
So, Mountain Dew Sweet lightning
is like peach Mountain Dew,
and it's really good.
It's really good. Mm!
Think this is a lemonade,
the US-style lemonade,
not that weird UK Sprite lemonade.
Oh, so good.
From there, you can also get Sierra Mist.
[sighs]
Ugh, ugh!
And, of course, sweet tea.
Whoa, that's, like, really sweet.
Oh, that's really good.
Exclusive drinks in KFC India.
We have Mirinda, which is an orange soda,
and Red Bull.
Let's talk about Mirinda.
This is a drink that
really evokes nostalgia.
'90s kids will know what I'm
talking about when I say,
"Mirindaaaaa."
Which country is getting
the better deal on its KFC?
Let's compare a few
menu items to find out.
Both countries offer
eight-piece chicken bucket.
Here in LA, one of these goes for $19.99.
If you order an eight-piece chicken bucket
here at KFC India,
it will cost you 699.05 rupees,
very specific,
which is currently 9.15 US dollars.
That makes the American eight-piece bucket
118% more expensive than the one in India.
Does making your meal a combo
help the US price out at all?
Take this chicken-sandwich
combo, with fries and a drink.
It will set you back, in America, $9.99.
The Indian equivalent is a Zinger meal,
where you can get a chicken
sandwich, some medium fries,
and a drink for 319.05 rupees,
or 4.18 US dollars.
In fact, the price difference is so great,
you can get something called
the Ultimate Savings Bucket
for just 599 rupees, or $7.88.
And this contains four pieces
of hot and crispy chicken,
six hot wings, four boneless strips,
three drinks, and three dips. Yeesh.
In fact, you can throw in a
choco mud pie as a dessert
and still get all of this for much cheaper
than the American combo meal.
But is it really that cheap here in India?
No, because two-thirds of India
is still under the poverty line,
and for them, this meal is
still very aspirational.
They earn less than $2 a day.
Sorry to be a downer,
but this is still a meal
that is only available
to the really privileged here in India.
Unfortunately, KFC does
not share a full list
of ingredients with the public.
It's actually the same in the US.
All KFC shares with the
public is a list of allergens.
So, what do we know about KFC?
Well, the KFC India website
has a couple of clues.
We know that all of our
chicken is farmed here
and not imported,
and all of it is 100%
whole muscle chicken.
That means it's made from
whole pieces of chicken
and not cut-together minced chicken,
like you find in chicken nuggets.
In fact, the website says they
have an open-kitchen policy,
and what that means is
anybody can walk into a KFC
and apparently ask for a kitchen tour.
And you can go into the
kitchen, look at everything,
and ask as many questions as you want.
I have never heard of
that in my entire life,
an open-kitchen policy.
I've worked in several kitchens,
and I'll tell you straight up,
if I was in a kitchen working
and some dude walks in
and is like, "Hey, can I
get a tour of the kitchen?"
I'd be like, "Yeah, here's
your tour. There's the exit."
Definitely can't do that
in the United States.
Don't go into a KFC
chicken and demand a tour.
The KFC US website also
gives us some hints
about the ingredients it uses over here.
For instance, all of our
chicken is raised on US farms
to the USDA and FDA's standards.
So that means there are no added hormones
or steroids in American KFC chicken.
In addition to this, as of 2019,
Yum Brands, the parent company of KFC,
stopped purchasing chicken
raised using antibiotics.
Indian chicken farmers
were previously criticized
for overusing antibiotics.
As recently as 2018, The Bureau
of Investigative Journalism
found out that a lot of Indian
farmers were feeding colistin
to their chickens as a growth promoter
without any medical supervision.
Colistin is known as the
antibiotic of the last resort.
Holy f---.
Oh, my God, that's so frightening!
And it's only given to humans
when other antibiotics have failed.
So if we give our chickens colistin,
then the humans who consume it
might become resistant to it.
In fact, they can develop a
antibiotic-resistant superbug,
and that's not good.
Yuelei, this sounds like
the plot to a horror movie.
What is he talking about?
That is terrifying.
I'm gonna assume we don't do that here?
And if we do, oh, God.
But when a report came out
talking about the ill effects of colistin,
India ended up banning it completely,
so we're safe from colistin, at last.
We should also point out
that the KFC India website
is in major need of an update.
There is an FAQ page where
people have asked things like,
"How many calories does
this chicken have?"
Or, "Sometimes I see red
deposits in my chicken.
What is it?"
And for almost all of these questions,
the answers are just filler text.
So if you ask me what
those red deposits are,
I genuinely don't know.
That's interesting. Let's take a look
at this website right now.
Ahem. "Is KFC providing
healthcare to their employees?"
KFC responds,
"standard dummy text ever since the 1500s,
when an unknown printer
took a gallery of type
and scrambled it to make
a type specimen book."
Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Starbucks in India and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
At a Starbucks in India,
we get our hot coffees in four sizes.
No. 1,
Nikhil: a short,
Joe: Short,
Nikhil: a tall,
Joe: tall,
Nikhil: a grande,
Joe: grande,
and the big boy,
Nihil: a venti.
Joe: venti.
I can't think of a single reason
you would order a coffee of this size.
Who is putting this much
caffeine in their body?
Me, Nikhil. Me.
Let's measure this to see if
it has as much as it should.
Joe: Whoa, wait a second.
Starbucks, I'm disappointed.
It's close. It's 18 ounces, ish.
All right, if I'm paying
this kind of money,
I want a bang for my
buck. 20 ounces to the T.
I think that's 20.
I was about to dunk on Starbucks,
but they actually gave
us the 20 they promised.
Cheers.
Ah.
Look into the eyes
of an insane caffeine addict.
My vision has just gone blurry.
India's iced coffee comes in three sizes.
Both: Tall.
Grande.
Venti.
And an even bigger one, we got the trenta.
I want to mention now
that our venti iced size
is bigger than our venti hot size.
The venti hot was 20 ounces.
This is 24 ounces.
And, of course, let's measure it.
Nikhil: Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Can't believe we have done this.
It's not even 16 ounces, Starbucks.
And this has ice in it,
which should melt and
give you more liquid.
Is that how fluid dynamics works?
Maybe not.
But my disappointment is palpable.
Yeah, I'm gonna go 22 ounces.
I don't know. It's 2 ounces. That's fine.
[laughing]
It's totally not a big deal.
That's, like, two sips.
I can't speak for anyone else,
but already my bladder is about to burst.
So maybe I don't need 24 more
ounces in my bloodstream.
If that wasn't exciting enough,
we of course have our biggest iced size,
which is the trenta. 30 fluid ounces.
The bladder buster.
This is for anyone who wants to spend
most of their day in the bathroom.
So you think, what, 28?
Again, 2 ounces off.
You know, Starbucks, 4
ounces more won't kill you.
Ah, this is actually pretty good.
Starbucks actually good? What the hell?
Anyone who watches "Food Wars" knows
we use this measuring cup for everything.
And I know I don't clean it,
and I don't think Joe's cleaning it,
and I don't think Yuelei's cleaning it.
So this thing, never
been cleaned -- yeah, mm.
And of course, if you're in the mood
for 96 fluid ounces of Starbucks coffee,
ba-bam!
Get yourself the coffee traveler,
aka what Joe drinks in an afternoon.
Here in India, we don't
have a huge coffee traveler.
We just have this little guy.
It's an India-edition
tiny pet coffee traveler.
It's got a lot of cool
India iconography on it.
There's a batsman, there is an elephant,
all sorts of cool Indian stuff.
And you can put in 355
ml of coffee in here,
which is around 11.83 ounces of coffee,
roughly a tall.
So, the perfect size.
We also have 1-liter bottles
for iced latte and cold brew.
Word on the street is
they contain 1 liter each,
or 33.8 fluid ounces.
It is so weird using the
US system of measurement.
I'm so used to our normal,
correct metric system.
But let's not start an actual
war over here. Sorry, Joe.
Yeah, um, I don't care.
Let's take a look at calories.
A hot venti latte in
India is 289 calories.
For comparison, a normal serving
of dal chawal is 200 calories.
[sighs]
In the US, the same venti café latte
is 250 calories.
So it looks like the US
has 13.5% less calories.
It's at that temperature where
it's, like, room temperature.
[Windows shutdown music]
My brain is Swiss cheese.
Everything I say is idiotic.
A hot venti mocha,
which is also what my friends call me,
is 473 calories.
And in the US, our venti
mocha is 450 calories.
So, according to my math, once again,
that's a calorie decrease of 4.9%.
What do you think of that, hot venti boy?
OK, Joe, it's not a competition.
Let's just try something a little sweeter,
like this venti caramel Frappuccino,
which looks, uh, decadent,
to say the least.
Oh, my God, that is so sweet.
602 calories.
And I can feel every single
one of them in each sip.
OK, genuinely, I have
had spoonfuls of sugar
that are more savory than this drink.
How can you make something
sweeter than sugar?
How?
That's a lot of calories, my man.
Ours is 470 calories,
which is also 24 ounces.
Now, I should note, in the US,
the calories listed on
Starbucks.com are, quote,
"based on standard recipes
and do not reflect customizations."
Get this out of my face. I hate this.
Why is this so -- and they put, like,
they load the syrup in here.
How can a human being drink one of these?
I don't understand.
And now, our most calorific overall drink
that we have here in India,
a venti strawberry and crème Frappuccino,
963 calories.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even think it was possible
to experience a sugar rush
and a coffee caffeine
high at the same time.
At 963 calories, this is nearly 50%
of your daily caloric intake.
So please drink this at your own risk.
And I am a risk-taker.
Whew.
I feel transported to another dimension
where everything is more colorful
and I can taste sound.
I don't know. I feel like
we should have an ambulance ready
if I'm going to finish this drink.
That's a lot of calories, I have to say.
I'm very impressed.
Our most highest calorific drink
is the mocha cookie crumble
Frappuccino at the venti size,
and it's only 590 calories.
Oh, God.
This looks so bad.
Oh, man. It's so powerful.
Like, it's so sweet
that everything from here
on for the rest of my life
is just going to taste like paper.
So, what about the cost?
This venti Frappuccino
will cost you 390 rupees,
which at the time of
filming this video is $5.14.
In the US, a venti caramel Frappuccino
is $5.45,
or about 413 Indian rupees.
Now, I want to point out
that this is 24 ounces
and not the India 20-ounce venti.
So if we break it down per fluid ounce,
it's about 11.5% cost per
fluid ounce decrease in the US.
Let me give you some context
about Starbucks in India.
They are catering to
the rich and the elite,
because it is very expensive over here.
In South India, where I'm from,
you can get a filter coffee
for less than 40 rupees,
which is a fraction of a
dollar, and it's delicious.
Starbucks would cost you upwards of $5,
and that's unaffordable for most of India.
Here is everything that
you can find in a menu
at an Indian Starbucks that
you won't get in the US.
Quick clarification.
Some of the items we have
here are location-specific
and specific to the season
that we're ordering them.
It's currently summer here in Mumbai,
and some of these items
are store-specific.
So maybe you won't get
them when you go order,
but let me know.
And here's everything you
can only find on the menu
at a US Starbucks you can't get in India.
Now, a bit of clarification.
We know Starbucks will
customize drink orders
and there are thousands of variations
and special secret menu items.
Thank you, Starbucks.
So just to make things
not completely insane,
these are the official
things on the Starbucks menu
at both India and the US.
Cool, and let's go.
All right, let's begin with
all the hot exclusive drinks,
starting with salted caramel latte.
Not bad.
Stardust mocha.
Boom, we have clarified, no sparkles.
Nothing about this screams stardust.
I don't know what you're
talking about, Starbucks,
but it tastes good.
Chai tea, or as we call
it here in India, chai.
Can I just say, it's a bit of a pet peeve
when you guys call chai "chai tea."
It's like calling tea "tea tea."
Let me describe a good chai to you.
All right, it should be
warm. It should be gingery.
It should feel like a hug from
your mum in your childhood,
and it should perk your morning up.
And it should be under 10
rupees, but this is expensive.
Hello! It's Crystelle, and
I'm here to talk about chai,
which is actually my favorite drink.
Every person has their
own recipe for chai,
but it's a combination
of spices and black tea
and some milk, and usually
sweetened with a bit of sugar.
But for me at home, in my recipe,
cardamom is the most important spice,
cinnamon, ginger, a pinch of cloves,
and my secret spice is
a bit of black pepper,
just to give that lovely,
warming, spicy feeling,
but it's not savory.
It's just a lovely blend of spices.
The flavor is not bad,
but I wouldn't call this,
I wouldn't call this a chai.
You know what? This is a chai tea!
Because it's not quite a chai,
it's not quite a tea.
Fair enough, Starbucks. It's a chai tea.
Next up, and the drink
I'm most excited to have,
thandai spice.
Now, thandai is consumed
primarily in North India
in the state of Uttar Pradesh,
where it's this drink that's sweet.
It contains spices, it
contains rose petals, saffron,
and sometimes, optionally,
you can add bhang,
which is marijuana, and
it's completely free,
legal, and optional to add it.
And people enjoy it during the festivals
like Holi and Maha Shivratri.
What, I'm sorry, did he say that
that drink has marijuana in it?
Or you can put weed in it?
I mean, this is California.
So if there's a drink you can put weed in,
you'd think that we would have it, right?
Not bad!
It's got little pieces
of pista and badam and other nuts.
How did you get thandai right
and mess up something as simple as a chai?
USA, we got a lot of hot exclusives.
I'm going to start all the way down here,
with something called the caffè misto.
Bland.
Moving on.
Almond honey flat white.
This flat white I like
because it has a nice honey flavor to it,
but straight-up flat whites,
I just, I don't get it.
Cinnamon dolce latte.
I like it. It's not too sweet.
A white hot chocolate.
Hot chocolate? Come on.
This is, like, really good,
but I don't know if I could
drink a whole one of those.
This is the caramel apple spice.
No, thanks.
Steamed apple juice.
What? Apple juice?
Hot apple juice. When are you gonna,
"Ooh, I want some apple
juice right about now"?
"I haven't seen you in forever!
Let's meet up for apple juice."
Cinnamon dolce crème.
Ugh!
Steamed milk.
Eh, barf!
Vanilla crème.
When you walk past that ice
cream place in the mall,
it tastes the way it
smells, like strong vanilla.
I couldn't imagine having
more than two sips of that.
Already my stomach's starting to hurt.
I'm gonna be so sick.
And now it's time for the cold exclusives.
I'm not having a caffeine crash at all.
[error ding]
The citrus cold brew.
Citrusy.
Out of everything, this one has
kind of a nice, mild flavor.
The cocoa chai almond.
Ooh, I just had such a mild one.
I took a big sip, and
this one is sweet again.
Vietnamese caramel cold brew.
It should typically have condensed milk,
but this has normal milk,
and it's quite good.
Nitro cold brew.
It's basically cold brew,
but if you press a button,
you drink it faster.
[ba-dum tish]
Dumb joke.
It tastes like any other cold brew.
I'd be interested to know
what the nitrogen process is.
What is nitro cold brew?
Well, they add nitrogen to it.
And you know what that does?
I have no idea.
Next up, chocolate truffle cold brew.
You know, that sounds like
something your child self
and your adult self would want to combine
if they had to collaborate on a drink.
Let's see if it's actually good.
Absolutely not.
Oh, my God, stardust mocha again.
Mm.
I still don't know what
the hell stardust is.
There are chunks of something.
Something otherworldly.
It's like cookies and cream. It's an Oreo.
It's an Oreo!
Thandai spice, same flavor, but now cold.
Mm,
hm!
Too much sugar for one
young man to consume.
I'm losing it!
I'm seeing the light.
Oh, no, I'm literally seeing the light.
There's a light above me.
You know, the funny thing is
thandai is meant to be consumed cold,
so this is the appropriate
temperature and way to drink it.
But it's layered with
so much whipped cream,
and it's so sweet.
Thandai requires a balance
of spices and sweetness,
and that's what this is lacking.
And the final two drinks
are salted caramel
and strawberry with cream,
but I already tasted those.
Maybe it got better with
time, you never know.
You ought to give everything a chance.
I'm never giving anything
a chance ever again.
And now for the pre-bottled drinks.
They've got three of
them in 1-liter bottles.
This is the iced shaken hibiscus lemonade.
Looks quite refreshing.
Mm.
That is very nice.
It says it serves four to five cups,
which, if you're in an Indian family,
they're going to make this
last for at least 20 people.
And it's very reminiscent of Rooh Afza,
which is a rose flavoring
that we add to water,
and it's super delicious.
I think this is a good substitute.
White mocha caramel cold brew.
Oh, my God.
I've gotten to the stage
where I can smell sugar.
I can see sugar.
I can hear sugar.
I think I am sugar at this point.
Starbucks signature chocolate.
Normally I would be
very excited about this,
but I am so soaked to the
brim with sweet stuff.
It's actually good.
It's, like, the amount of chocolate
you want to put in your cocoa,
but you know it's
probably not good for you.
I'm losing my goddamn mind. [laughs]
All right, starting down here.
Something you can only get in the US
is the mocha cookie crumble Frappuccino.
It's looking a little sad.
So, "Food Wars" tip, bring your own whip.
That's another one of Joe's tips!
Mm, I'm not getting the cookie part of it.
It just tastes like a chocolate milkshake.
I don't know if that's really
doing much for the flavor.
The caramel ribbon crunch Frappuccino.
I don't know how anyone could
drink a whole one of these.
The recommended serving for this, Joe,
should be, like, two sips.
It's like, sip No. 2,
and I'm good for a week.
Ugh.
The high-fructose corn syrup
is working overtime in that one.
The caffè vanilla Frappuccino.
You know I always keep this thang on me.
The least objectionable one, I guess.
Actually a little weak, to be honest.
Then again, after these two,
maybe it's perfectly fine.
Nitro, the official cold brew
of the "Fast and Furious"
franchise, Joseph.
Just pour this on your
engine, and off you go,
off you and Vin Diesel go.
It doesn't require ice.
Has a smoother flavor, right?
Now, if you want something
a little bit sweeter
in your cold brew,
you can get yourself a vanilla
sweet cream nitro cold brew.
Joe fucks with it.
We got a vanilla oat milk,
we got a brown sugar oat milk,
and we got a chocolate almond milk.
Here they are.
Not as strong of a flavor
as I thought it would be.
Brown sugar.
I'm definitely tasting it.
Yeah, not bad.
I have reason to believe
this was unshooken.
Think I could shake it without?
I would recommend this
one out of all three,
but insist they shake it in front of you.
You can get yourself an iced flat white
and an iced honey flat white.
Skip 'em.
Iced cinnamon dolce latte
and an iced Starbucks blond latte.
Not bad.
Can confirm a sip is good.
I don't know about a whole one of these.
Already I'm kind of like, eh.
Starbuck teas,
or, as my mum calls them,
"I can make this at home."
Starting off with Indian spice majestic.
Wow, OK.
Oh! Can I just say,
drinking this after everything else
is such a breath of fresh air.
You know, it's a simple tea,
but it's very flavorful, very spicy.
Would recommend.
Next up, matcha espresso fusion.
It's part of the trifecta
of three ingredients
that have become very popular in India.
Matcha, peri-peri, and red velvet.
I feel like the espresso counters
the sweetness that it has,
and the matcha flavor's there.
Again, just cut down on the sweetness,
and this would actually be good.
Now, the exclusive hot teas
you get here in the US.
The royal English breakfast tea latte,
London fog tea latte,
honey citrus mint tea,
a jade citrus mint brewed tea,
the mint majesty.
Mint, matcha, green, all bad.
The trinity of gross. I don't want it.
The peach tranquility.
And they spell it "tranquility,"
but it should be tranquili-T-E-A.
I feel like they missed a trick there.
OK, so those are the two hot teas.
It's now time for the cold teas,
starting with an iced green tea.
I feel like when you
start drinking green tea,
it's a sign of adulthood,
and there's no going back.
That's actually pretty good.
And now I feel old.
Hibiscus passion lemonade.
So many ingredients,
but I know I'm going to taste only sugar.
Hey, that's pretty good.
It's kind of flowery, fruity.
I really like this.
A maveha espresso fusion.
Oh, this is an iced matcha?
Oh, OK, sorry.
My bad, my bad. It's,
guys, it's the Starbucks handwriting.
Honestly, sometimes I think it's just
doctors writing prescriptions
on these coffee mugs.
By the way, let me know in the comments,
what's the weirdest way
somebody has spelled your name
in Starbucks?
Mm. I prefer this to
the weird hot sweet one.
Yeah, I like the teas way
more than the coffees.
So, I don't know what
that says about Starbucks,
but I'm a fan.
I feel the exact opposite.
I do not like tea at all.
And this is all the
stuff on a Starbucks menu
I have never gotten and
would like to never get.
But, gotta do it. It's the job.
So we will start down here.
At the Starbucks in the
US, you can get yourself
iced black tea and an
iced black tea lemonade.
Moving on, you can get peach teas.
We got an iced peach green tea
and an iced peach tea lemonade.
So, this tastes good because
it's peach and lemonade.
I don't taste any tea.
Green iced green tea lemonade.
Oh, grande, not -- the first GR is grande.
Grande iced green tea latte.
"Latte." Lemonade.
Ugh, I'm losing it. See? I don't,
I stop drinking caffeine for
a second, and I fall apart.
Oh, matcha? No!
No, not matcha!
Grande matcha lemonade.
All right, lemonade.
Lemonade is doing all the
heavy lifting on all of these.
I absolutely hate this.
Royal English breakfast.
Mm!
You know what'll help?
A little caffeine.
Mm!
Whoo! All right.
Also at Starbucks, you can get
something called Refreshers.
From what I can tell,
they are fruit juices
with fruit in it. Imagine that.
I would never normally get a Refresher,
I just wouldn't think to, but
now I get to try all of them!
Pink drink!
Ooh, yeah. Fruity.
Moving on, we have the
strawberry acai lemonade.
I like this.
Similar problem to a
lot of the Frappuccinos.
One taste, and I'm like,
I could get into it.
But a whole one of these,
I feel my gut kind of starting to, blech.
Just the mango dragon fruit, right?
Dragon drink.
Mango dragon fruit lemonade.
I think this is the best one so far.
[beep]
One second. All right. Don't put that in.
Moving on, we have the green drink zone.
Star drink. Assuming star fruit.
Kiwi star fruit.
Does lemonade kick it
up even another notch?
Hm, this one, I like the flavor the best,
but it's a little strong.
Yeah, all these are pretty good.
The last Refresher is the
strawberry acai.
They have a regular lemonade
and a blended strawberry lemonade.
I mean, come on. Lemonade?
Everything else that's had
lemonade in it, I've enjoyed.
So let's just go straight to the source.
Whoa, dude.
Starbucks lemonade is, like, really good.
Is this even in the top
10 things you would get
at Starbucks, a lemonade? What?
Now, if you like your lemonade,
a little bit of strawberry.
This is fantastic.
Wow.
Even after all these, this is a standout.
This is really good.
Why is this so good?
Fantastic.
Food!
We have a lot of Indian exclusives.
I'm going to start with the salads.
This is a vegetarian grain salad.
It's got quinoa, it's
got some paneer in it,
it's got corn kernels that look unborn.
I'm sure this is super healthy,
but it's also very dry.
Now the meat version of
it. It's got chicken.
I'm not really a fan of cold salads.
If you are a health freak,
you might enjoy this.
But if you're a fan of
food, you probably won't.
OK, next up, I'm going to
try all of their rolls.
Rolls are a huge staple here in India.
They're one of the most
famous street foods,
and it's great for the
working-class citizen.
This is the murgh kathi roll.
Murgh means chicken in Hindi.
Oh, that's pretty good.
Finally! Some spice!
Oh, my God. This is a life-saver.
I feel like I'm being brought back to life
after all those drinks.
This is really good.
You'll find this only in
India, but honestly, Starbucks,
you should consider selling this all over,
because it is tasty.
Next up is a kakori kebab roll.
Kakori kebab is basically
minced meat, typically lamb,
and it's served with a paratha or a roti.
I've never seen it in a roll,
and I've never seen it in a pink roll.
Mm, you can see.
The main thing about a kakori kebab is
it should melt in your mouth.
This has too much of a bite to it.
Not a fan.
Next up, chatpata paneer roll.
Chatpata means full of masala
and flavor, and it's zingy.
And paneer is cottage cheese.
We love our cottage cheese here in India,
and we call it paneer. And you should too.
Next up, cheese chili toast.
So, obviously, if you
order this at Starbucks,
I assume they actually toast
this and the cheese melts
and it's super delicious.
I can tell you right now,
this flavor profile will go
really well with Indians.
We love our cheese chili toast.
Monsoon season, mum goes to the kitchen,
toasts the bread, lot of
butter, some cheese, some chili.
Bite into it, your mouth's on fire,
but it's rainy and cold, so you're all OK.
This is not quite there,
but I feel like it could be.
Next up, tandoori paneer sandwich.
I'm gonna have to say that
this bread is a little hard,
to say the least.
Might be a bit of an old sandwich.
Flavor is good, though.
If I had any of this food
fresh at a Starbucks,
I might have a very different opinion.
So far, the paneer items
have been way better
than the meat items.
I'm starting to guess there's somebody
in the Starbucks R&D team
who really likes paneer.
Sandwiches and protein boxes, here we go.
You can get a bunch of
exclusive sandwiches,
US Starbucks, starting right here,
with the crispy grilled
cheese on sourdough, again.
Ham and cheese on a baguette.
Then we get the turkey pesto
with provolone on ciabatta.
Chicken and bacon on brioche.
Why is it -- could we get that chicken
on the whole thing here, guys?
A focaccia tomato mozzarella.
At a Starbucks, you can get
a chicken caprese on ciabatta sandwich.
On to the protein boxes.
The chickpea bites and avocado.
You can tell what's in there.
Obviously avocado, chickpea bites.
Egg and cheddar.
Cheese and fruit.
Peanut butter and jam.
Grilled chicken and hummus.
There's your hummus,
there's your pita, there's
your grilled chicken.
You can also get,
which was not available
at the store today,
egg and Gouda protein box,
a cheese trio protein box,
and a cheddar and salami protein box.
Next up, egg white and
chicken multigrain croissant.
Should I just call it a
croy-sant to upset people,
the denizens of the internet?
If you are somebody trying
to be protein-conscious,
put on the pounds, this
might be good for you.
Next up, a masala chicken croissant.
I guess you can't go
wrong with masala chicken.
You can go wrong with a croissant.
This tastes really good.
Next up, a basil, tomato,
mozzarella sandwich.
I can imagine just eating
this on a summer day.
Really yum.
Next up, creamy spinach and corn pocket.
Pocket! That's pretty cute.
As a kid, this was the only
way I enjoyed eating spinach,
unless it was in palak paneer.
But right now, I appreciate,
and I really like it in this pocket.
Next up, chicken seekh pocket.
Seekh kebab is basically minced meat,
and it's sort of pressed onto
a skewer and then grilled.
Over here, they've done
that, and then they've
chopped them into little sausage pieces.
Mm. Minty, it has that pudina flavor,
a lot of onions that have
just been caramelized,
so it's sweet but also
spicy. I really like this.
Starting with the breakfast
sandwiches and wraps,
the bacon, Gouda, egg. There's
Gouda somewhere on here.
A sausage, egg, and cheddar.
The double-smoked bacon,
cheddar, and egg. Dude.
It's good.
Ham and Swiss croissant.
A bacon, sausage, and egg wrap.
What's up?
I didn't ...
Other sandwiches you can get are
spinach, feta, egg wrap,
the roasted ham,
the turkey bacon, cheddar,
and egg white sandwich,
and the Impossible breakfast sandwich.
But you know what they do have?
Bacon and Gruyère.
Egg white and roasted red pepper.
Kale and mushroom.
Get yourself an avocado
spread. For dipping.
Bagels!
We got 'em.
Can I assume this is an everything?
'Cause it's got everything.
Cinnamon raisin.
I can tell because of the raisins.
Hey, plain. For the New Yorker, right?
Oatmeal! Oatmeal.
We got regular, and they
come with a nut medley,
brown sugar, dried fruit.
I bet it's like a puck now.
It's been sitting for a while.
All right. [crew laughing]
You can also get a blueberry one.
It's obviously just same
stuff with blueberries.
Strawberry and overnight grains.
Next up, a double chocolate chip cookie.
I think if I put this in a
microwave for five seconds,
this is a banging, banging cookie.
A tea cake.
This is lemon-flavored.
And finally, they have a banana loaf cake,
but, guys, I am dangerously
allergic to banana.
And so I wish this cake the best of luck.
Maybe you guys can try it and
let me know in the comments
whether it's worth ordering.
On to the baked goods. In the US,
you can get an assortment of baked goods,
as you can see in front of me.
I'll just start down here. We got scones.
Oh, this is a blueberry scone.
Petite vanilla bean scone.
These can't be the same price.
Cake pops.
You got chocolate.
Which one do you think is Earth
and which one do you think is birthday?
I feel like this has got to be birthday.
Glazed doughnut, ay.
Red velvet cake.
Pumpkin loaf.
You can also get a cinnamon coffee cake.
Yeah, brownie.
Chocolate chip cookie.
Available, yet not today,
pumpkin cream cheese muffin.
It is now time for ice creams.
Did you know Starbucks makes ice creams?
I had no idea.
Java chip ice cream.
This looks really good.
Check it out, son.
Yum!
Coffee, chocolate chips, and mocha.
That is something else.
I really like this.
Next up, vanilla ice
cream and chocolate sauce.
Now, everybody in India,
their childhood has involved
Amul vanilla ice cream
and Hershey's chocolate syrup.
Let's see if this sort
of evokes that nostalgia.
Ooh, the vanilla ice cream is so good.
Next up, vanilla ice cream
with strawberry sauce.
You either got the
Hershey's chocolate sauce
or the Hershey's strawberry sauce.
Younger Kini would not
have appreciated this,
but older Kini, really enjoying it.
It's fruity, tangy, sour,
and it really complements
the yummy vanilla creamy ice cream.
Next up, we have the same java chip,
but now with more chocolate
chips and chocolate sauce.
So, this is a bit of an overload.
Too much.
Are you, can you zoom in on my hand?
It's shaking right now.
Caramel macchiato.
Mm. It's really nice.
It's not too sweet. It's kind of salty.
Next, the affogato, which
is ice cream in coffee.
I love how we're taking
hot, bitter coffee,
and sweet, creamy ice
cream, mixing them together,
and somehow they're not choosing violence.
They're choosing to be friends,
harmonious in my mouth.
Affogato again, but
this is house affogato.
So I'm going to assume, Starbucks,
that this should be better.
You're putting your name on it.
Tastes the same.
And, finally, we have the
caramel macchiato ice cream.
It's similar to the small cup
of caramel macchiato I had,
except this does not have
a drizzle of caramel sauce.
If you were ordering ice
cream from Starbucks,
I would recommend the simple java chip
and the simple caramel macchiato.
No drizzle of sauces.
It's not as sweet. It's kind of nice.
Joe: From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences between McDonald's in India and the US.
Joe: This is "Food Wars."
Drinks in McDonald's
India come in three sizes:
regular, medium, and large.
Drinks in the McDonald's
in the US, four sizes:
extra small, small, medium, and large.
Time to keep 'em honest.
Lost a couple drops. 26, 27 fluid ounces.
Whoo!
Hm.
Fries in India come in three sizes:
regular, medium, and large.
In America, our fries come
in four sizes, I think.
We have a small, kids,
or kids, small —
I can't tell the difference either —
medium, and large.
The medium and large
come in these really cool
new packaging where you can
just open it up like that
and it's nice and easy to share.
It's a little plate.
Good job, McDonald's. Very innovative.
But now it's time to measure
and see how much we're really getting.
Joe: First things first, the large.
175 grams.
Obviously it's different
per scoops or whatever.
Yeah, let's go here.
This one, almost exactly 100 grams.
This one,
80 grams.
Fry math, hang on.
This is, like...
yep, there you go.
That's a 20-gram difference right there.
So, you tell me, internet.
Is the kids and the small different sizes?
I don't think they are.
"Food Wars" is on it! We're on it, baby!
What about McNuggets?
Here in India, you can
order them in three sizes:
six pieces, nine pieces, and 20 pieces.
They gave it to us in
two boxes of 10 each.
Oh, is that it, India? Cute.
Our McNuggets start at four,
then you got six,
10,
20,
and not to be outdone,
booyah, 40 McNuggets.
All the mathheads watching
will be quick to point out
that that is double India's
largest nugget option.
The only burger that
India shares with the US
is the McChicken,
the humble McChicken.
Not even gonna bother
with the analog scale now.
Boop!
149 grams.
Ah, just so frustrating.
Just one more gram and
it would be perfect.
With the paper? I mean, we'll do this and
shave off an eighth of an ounce.
Our McChicken weighs 140 grams.
Here is everything you'll find on the menu
at McDonald's India that you
will not find in the USA.
And here's all the McDonald's menu items
from the US you won't find in India.
Here in India, we can't really recreate
the iconic McDonald's Big Mac
because it's made from a beef patty,
and to keep to the religious sentiments
of Hindus and even Muslims,
we don't serve beef or pork
in a lot of fast-food restaurants.
We have something called
the chicken Maharaja Mac.
As you can see, it's got
three buns, two patties,
a lot of cheese and mayonnaise,
some tomatoes, onions, lettuce.
Lettuce try it now.
[ba-dum tish]
Oh, my God.
That is truly a Maharaja Mac.
If you're wondering, a raja is a king,
and a maharaja is like an emperor.
So this is clearly our
answer to the Big Mac.
Now let's taste the veg Maharaja Mac.
I think it's actually
a very cool challenge
that a lot of fast-food restaurants here
have had to adapt to the Indian palate,
as well as sensibilities of food.
We have come up with such
cool, iconic fast food
that you won't get
anywhere else in the world.
Like, look at this! This is outrageous!
There's no way to eat
this without being messy.
There's literally no way.
Mm!
Oh, my God. That's really good.
Yes to all that, looks really good.
Because of India's lack of beef,
all the American beef options
are technically exclusives.
All right.
Big Mac.
There it is, just brimming with stuff.
My go-to for, like, 20 years.
I still get it occasionally.
The classic McDonald's hamburger.
Beef patty, ketchup, and mustard.
Of course, you can get it with cheese. Hi.
You can upgrade to a double
cheeseburger or a McDouble.
What's the difference, you ask?
I'm not sure either.
So let's start with the
double cheeseburger.
Look at that. Look how yellow that is.
Beef, cheese, beef, cheese, toppos.
The McDouble is beef, cheese, beef.
So it's just one slice of cheese
in the middle, but not on top.
What's the price difference?
Can we get that on-screen?
And how much is a slice of cheese?
Joe's hack, get yourself a McDouble
and bring your own slice
of American cheese.
Booyah. Save yourself
this amount of money.
The problem with millennials today,
the reason you guys can't buy houses is
you're spending all
your money at Starbucks,
you're getting your double cheeseburgers
instead of a McDouble and
bringing your own cheese slice.
I mean, you guys are terrible with money!
You're eating, what, seven,
eight McDoubles a day like me, right?
And that adds up to, like,
at the end of the year, $18?
10,000 years later, that's
a down payment on a house.
What are you guys doing?
All right, next up is the
iconic McAloo tikki burger.
You take mashed potato, and
you fry it in breadcrumbs,
and you get this really delicious cutlet.
Here in India, they
adapted it into this burger
with a very special sauce,
some tomato, and chopped onions.
Mm. It's just so classic.
They nailed this burger.
Next up, there is a Mexican McAloo tikki,
which I assume has some
stereotypical Mexican ingredients
and flavors like jalapeño.
Yes! Jalapeño.
Mm, nice.
It's way more spicy. Good twist.
Next up, they have a McEgg burger.
McEgg. McEgg, McEgg.
I don't know why I did that.
Let's see what that looks like.
Ugh!
Sorry.
I did not expect... pesto?
Next up is a chicken kebab burger.
Every time an Indian
fast-food chain tries to adapt
an Indian special food into a burger,
I take it with a pinch of salt
because this is not what
we're used to seeing
when we think of kebabs,
but I'm going to try it,
and let's see what happens.
Mm.
It's very, very dry.
Patty has almost a
cardboard-y taste to it.
I wouldn't put those flavors together
if I was thinking kebab.
McCardboard tikki, maybe? No? OK.
That's a bit harsh. I'm sorry.
Next up is the McVeggie,
which is the vegetarian
counterpart to our McChicken.
If I had to eat this
versus the chicken one,
I would not be upset at all.
Really good.
Next up, we have two "American" burgers:
the American Cheese Supreme veg
and the American Cheese Supreme chicken.
My hunch for what makes them American
is that they will have a
nice big square of cheese
and they will not be spicy at all.
Except they have a lot
of jalapeños on them.
Joe, let me know if this
constitutes "American."
That's American cheese, my man.
That's what makes it American.
I don't know about those
other toppings, but,
yeah, it sounds about right.
All right, so this is what
the McDonald's website
says is in this burger.
"Whole-wheat buns
sourced from Maharashtra,
tangy jalapeños from Karnataka,
shredded onions grown
in local Indian farms,
and cheese from Amaravati, also in India."
Quite close to home, this burger.
Currently, this would
probably be my favorite order,
a McSpicy chicken, and
there's the vegetarian option,
which is a McSpicy paneer,
which is just leaking lettuce.
For those of you who
don't know what paneer is,
it's basically cottage cheese.
We love our paneer.
We put it in curries, we eat
it plain, we put it in kebabs.
It is so delicious. Let's try this.
Mm. It has just the right kick,
and it goes really well with the paneer.
Fair warning, while this
may have a light kick
of spice for us, it might
be a hard kick for you.
So, take everything with
a pinch of chili powder.
Gonna move up to something
called the Quarter Pounder,
and that's, like, their big burger.
So you can get a Quarter
Pounder with cheese.
Here it is.
I mean, it looks fake, right?
Like, "Just kidding, it's cake!"
Or the new one is, "It's
actually a candle!"
And then you can get a Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe.
More veggies on it, all
the junk that I brush off.
You can upgrade to a double
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Let's take a look. Oh, man.
Look how thick this is!
And then you can get that
same double with bacon.
Yeah!
Oh, man. Skimping on the bacon. Guys!
What we lack in beef
burgers we make up for
in gourmet burgers.
That's right. Here at McDonald's India,
we have our own collection of
chef's special gourmet burgers.
Delicious.
And I think this is a rolling menu.
I think they introduce new
things from time to time.
The buns themselves
look a lot more gourmet.
You know, there's a nice
rift down the middle.
Kind of looks like a butt, but that's OK.
We're not gonna concentrate on that.
First up, we have triple
cheese American veg burger
and triple cheese American
chicken burger.
Same thing. Cheese, jalapeño,
some sauce, lettuce,
simple chicken patty, gourmet bun.
Does this scream "American" to you?
Next up, Cheese Lava American veg burger
and Cheese Lava American chicken burger,
again with American
and again with the strange relation
of food to volcanoes and lava.
OK.
This burger is very spicy.
This qualifies as a
volcano product, for sure.
Congratulations, McDonald's.
The lava in the title
of this burger works.
The McSpicy chicken premium, though,
has an egg patty inside of it.
Mm-mm.
Mm, that's pretty good.
I just feel so existential right now.
Imagine sitting here at this table
and just tasting every single
burger on a McDonald's menu.
Amazing.
But also, s---.
We also have some exclusive wrap options.
We have Big Spicy paneer
and Big Spicy chicken.
I think this is the same
McSpicy chicken patty,
and it's wrapped around a tortilla,
which is actually way
closer to an Indian chapati
than most other fast-food restaurants.
It doesn't feel as synthetic.
Our McDonald's in the US
had wraps for a brief period of time.
One day they were gone. Nobody noticed.
Yeah, you guys got some chicken
stuff that we don't have,
but we got a few of our own.
More recently than you think,
they finally introduced
their chicken sandwich
to an already-crowded
chicken-sandwich market,
and that is of course their
crispy chicken sandwich,
and this thing is fantastic.
It's one of the best ones.
They were late to the game,
and they kind of took
it over, in my opinion.
And what I like about it,
it's simple. Look at this.
You just got crispy
chicken, pickles that suck.
It's baller. It tastes great.
Like it a little spicy, India?
It probably doesn't
compare to what you guys
are rocking in India but, you know,
this one has a little nice heat to it.
Pickles, sauce.
Want to take it up a notch?
Gotta go deluxe.
The cool crispness of the vegetables
just clash so well with the spicy sauce.
It's good. It's good.
Nikhil, say the word,
and I'm putting one in
the post for you tomorrow.
So when it arrives in three weeks,
you can throw it out.
Now we're getting into
exclusive side dishes.
Here in India, we have these add-ons.
No. 1, the veg pizza McPuff.
This is one of the most
delicious things we have here.
It's basically a pizza Hot Pocket.
Masala wedges. These are potato wedges
with classic Indian masala flavor to them.
Ooh, boy.
Masalas are basically what we use
to spice and flavor dishes,
and they consist primarily
of ground-up spices
like cardamom, cloves,
red chilies, Kashmiri chilies.
You go to every Indian home, the mums,
the grandmums will have
their own random, you know,
masala mix that they
use and that's guarded
and treasured in their family, forever.
Next up, we have cheesy masala wedges.
They're also serving a
classic cup of boiled corn,
which is so unique, and they
give you a side of Amul butter.
Guys, Amul butter is part of our culture.
Makhan. Makhan!
This is probably going to be
the most delicious bite of the day.
I love corn.
Next up, chicken strips.
They come in packs of two, three, or five.
Cheesy nugget veg bites.
Yeah, this is just a vegetarian version
of the chicken nuggets,
and it's got some corn, some tomato.
Mm, it's OK.
Next, we have the double cheese McMuffin.
And lastly, we have Mexican cheesy fries.
On the McDonald's India website,
one British customer said
that these Mexican cheesy
fries are "the real deal."
I have no idea how a
British person can say
that Mexican cheesy
fries are the real deal,
but anytime a British person says
that another culture's
food is "the real deal,"
it puts a little fear in
our small Indian hearts.
Yeah those fries look like ass.
And the next exclusive side
that we have is apple slices.
Cut 'em up, put 'em in a plastic bag.
'Bout to get saucy. That's
right, ladies and gentlemen.
Sauce talk.
Thank you.
Spicy Buffalo.
Not that good.
We got a tangy barbecue.
Ooh.
Much better.
Mm. Honey mustard.
Tastes like salad dressing.
Sweet and sour.
I would tie it with the tangy barbecue
because it's so different,
so we'll keep these guys
same tier.
Ranch, I don't know.
America, we love our ranch.
Ranch is just OK.
That's right, I said it. Ranch is just OK.
Oh, and all ranch tastes the same. Yeah.
And finally, honey.
How do you like that?
Honey's the best one.
And all that money, all that energy,
all that time creating all these recipes,
trying to sway the American mind,
and you got beat by a bunch of bees.
Power to the bees!
We have one exclusive spice mix
as well as one exclusive
sauce here in India.
We have chili sauce, which
is pretty straightforward.
It's chili sauce.
But let me tell you about
peri-peri spice mix.
So, McDonald's launched
this in 2013 here in India,
and it was so popular, there were riots
when they said they were
going to discontinue it.
And so now, it's a permanent
addition to the menu.
First, you get this shake bag,
then you grab your fries,
and then you just pour that in there.
Ah.
Boom! Oh, boy.
Can we cut to a before of the fries?
You saw how they were. Now look at these.
You can see the little flecks of spice
just adorning each fry.
Hello, it's Crystelle.
And I know Nikhil has
peri-peri McDonald's chips,
but in the UK, it is all about Nando's.
Cheeky Nando's.
Let's talk about peri-peri.
Peri means pepper. And
it's a blend of spices,
so it's got things like paprika,
ground bird's eye chili,
a bit of oregano, a pinch
of ginger and cardamom,
but it's a Portuguese spice blend.
It's funny because
obviously Nikhil mentioned
that the peri-peri fries
just blew off in India,
and it makes sense, because I'm from Goa,
which is in the south of India.
Goa was colonized by the Portuguese.
And so I really think that Indians
are accustomed to that
Portuguese taste palate,
which is why peri-peri fries
are doing so well in India.
But enough of the talking.
I want to dig into these
fries, because they look great.
Mm. Oh, this is so good.
Harry, get involved.
You're not eating chips
without me, are you?
Oh, sorry, I've already had a head start.
Harry: Cheers.
Crystelle: Cheers.
God damn, if that isn't like crack.
For the early risers,
there's plenty of
exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's.
Sausage biscuit with egg.
Next one,
sausage biscuit.
I mean, they take the
egg out, so it's just ...
This, of course, is
bacon, egg, and cheese.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we've reached the point of the breakfast
where we get into the McGriddles.
I love McGriddles.
What's a McGriddle, you ask,
India? Fantastic question.
McDonald's had this genius idea
to replace the breakfast
sandwiches they already had
with pancakes.
And they also, like, inject
syrup into it somehow?
But it is a breakfast sandwich
with pancakes for buns,
and it's the best idea anyone's
ever had, anywhere, ever.
[Joe laughing]
Look at this! Look at this, look at this.
They've even got a little M on there.
This mini pancake.
I know I'm wearing the
gloves, but this one's mine.
Mm.
We have a veg McMuffin
and a sausage McMuffin.
Mm.
The sausage here in India
is not made out of pork,
like it is in the US.
Instead, it's made out of simple chicken.
Speaking of sausage, you
can get a breakfast burrito.
Bro, I could put five of
these away, easy. Easy.
If you're, like, a total drag
and you want oatmeal in
the morning, we have it.
It's about as inspiring
as you would think.
Hotcakes and sausage.
Of course, it comes with hot syrup.
This here,
the big breakfast with hotcakes.
And it's big.
A lot of eggs, kind of
wimpy-looking bacon,
got yourself two English muffins here.
And, of course, comes with a hash brown.
Potatoes. Who doesn't love 'em?
McDonald's hash brown, undefeated.
These things are so good.
India exclusive desserts.
We have a Black Forest McFlurry,
a vanilla chocolate muffin,
and a chocolate chip muffin.
It's kind of like a
McFlurry soup right now.
This would be really good when
it was actually a McFlurry.
Desserts! USA, we got 'em.
So, starting down here, very simple,
chocolate chip cookies.
This next thing, apple fritter, right?
Mm.
This right here is called a
glazed pull-apart doughnut.
Blueberry muffin.
If you've had one, you've had them all.
This is a what type of pie?
Anders: A guava and cream pie.
Let's see what's inside.
OK. I'm suddenly more interested. Yeah!
Guava and cream.
How about we'll call it
the cream and guava pie?
Nah, this sucks.
[Anders laughing]
I don't f--- with it.
Standard menu item, the
McDonald's apple pie.
Everyone knows about this.
I don't want a pizza version of this.
Eh! And last but not least, cinnamon roll.
Too sticky. I don't feel like eating it.
Update: It's not sticky.
It's actually [knocks on cinnamon roll].
Exclusive drinks, starting with,
we have something called
B Natural's mixed fruit juice.
Next up, we have something
that they call raw mango fruit splash.
Oh!
It's a bit too sweet.
Berry lemonade splash.
All of these come in these very unique
reusable bottles, apparently.
Next up, strawberry chiller,
green apple chiller,
and lemon chiller.
It's just flavored water.
That's exactly what it is.
It's flavored water,
and I kind of like it.
This is a mixed berry smoothie.
It's still quite sweet, but quite good.
Next up, American mud pie shake.
Mm. That's pretty yum.
Drink roulette.
Ooh, and the ice melted. Fantastic.
Dr. Pepper. Let's go!
Coke, nonexclusive. Let's go.
Sweet tea, too sweet.
Ugh, yeah. Unsweetened
tea, not sweet enough.
You guys combine.
For the kids watching,
why are you watching?
Where are your parents or supervisors?
You can get yourself apple juice, milk.
Come on, you're drinking milk?
The thought of drinking straight milk,
like, hurts my stomach.
There's also chocolate milk on the menu.
Once upon a time,
this was an iced French vanilla latte.
Now it's more of a room-temperature
French vanilla latte.
That's just OK. It's, like, really sweet.
Strawberry banana smoothie.
Yeah, I always loved getting these.
These are good.
So I'm going to assume
they're not good for me.
Exclusive hot drinks.
First off, we have strawberry green tea.
Next up, English breakfast tea
and Moroccan tea.
Next up, a flat white coffee.
India, a land where we run on chai,
and McDonald's does
not have a chai option.
Caramel macchiato,
cappuccino,
caramel latte,
a vanilla cappuccino.
The V does look like a U.
McDonald's premium roast coffee.
I'm going to hang on to this one.
In India, a chicken Maharaja
Mac will cost you 231 rupees
for just the sandwich.
That's around $3.03.
We do not have the chicken Maharaja Mac,
but we do have the Big Mac,
and a Big Mac in the US costs $4.89.
That is a 61% price increase.
Now, what if you turn this into a meal?
A McSaver Maharaja Mac combo
comes with regular fries
and a regular drink and
will cost you 356 rupees.
That is $4.67, still less than the price
of the American sandwich on its own.
But does the combo meal
make a difference in the US?
A medium Big Mac combo,
so Big Mac, medium fries, medium drink,
is $8.99.
That's a 92% cost increase,
even worse than if you just
bought the sandwich on its own.
On the Indian McDonald's menu,
you'll find a two-person meal,
which contains a chicken
Maharaja Mac, a veg Maharaja Mac,
large fries, two pizza
McPuffs, and a drink.
All of this will cost
you 681 rupees, or $8.93.
So, basically, you're
getting food for two people
for the price of one
person's meal in the US.
However, while it seems a lot cheaper
than the food in the US,
it's still very expensive
and aspirational to people over here.
Your minimum wage per hour
is equal to our daily minimum wage.
And so, yeah,
a lot of people can't really
afford this kind of food.
The English-speaking Indians that you see
in a lot of YouTube videos on the internet
aren't really a proper reflection
of the majority of people
that live in this country,
who still can't afford food like this.
So, I'm checking my privilege,
and we should all make sure we check ours.
But let's play devil's advocate.
McDonald's India has definitely included
a lot more affordable
options on their menu.
And so they are more approachable
to the average urban Indian
than other fast-food chains.
Let's compare some items
to see who has the least
healthy McDonald's food.
In the US, a McChicken
contains 400 calories,
21 grams of fat, 39 grams of carbs.
5 of those are sugar,
and 560 milligrams of sodium.
How about the Indian McChicken?
One of these contains 398 calories,
15 grams of total fat, 48 grams of carbs,
5 grams of which are sugars,
787 milligrams of sodium.
So the Indian version has
slightly fewer calories,
way lesser fats, but much
more carbs and sodium.
What if we made that a combo meal?
Well, a medium fry in the
US contains the following:
320 calories, 15 grams of total fat,
43 grams of carbs, no sugar,
and 260 milligrams of sodium.
While a medium fries in
India contains 340 calories,
17 grams of total fat, 41 grams of carbs,
0 grams of sugars,
and 256 milligrams of sodium.
And if we add the medium Coke,
that is adding 210 calories, no fat,
56 grams of carbs, 56 of those are sugar,
and 55 milligrams of sodium.
Ooh, a nice salty Coke.
We'll do the same. Here in India,
one medium Coke will
cost you 151 calories,
0 grams of fat, 38 grams of carbs,
38 grams of which are sugars,
and there are 0 grams
of sodium, but my God,
that is a lot of sugar packed in this cup.
That leaves the Indian
meal at a grand total
of 889 calories, 32 grams of fat,
127 grams of carbs,
out of which 43 grams are sugars,
and 1,043 milligrams of sodium.
Sheesh.
Which means this whole bad boy altogether
is 930 calories,
36 grams of total fat,
138 grams of carbs,
61 of those grams are sugar,
875 milligrams of sodium.
Little bit lower sodium than India,
but we got you guys beat in
calorie, fats, carbs, and sugar.
Mm, mm, mm, mm! We win. We win.
Ah!
Unfortunately for India,
the combo stats are a little misleading,
and the difference maker is the Coke,
because the American meal
has a larger portion.
If you order the Coke
Zero in both countries,
the Indian meal will actually
have a higher calorie count.
McDonald's India does
not share a full list
of their ingredients,
but there are some things
we do know about their food.
Like, did you know that McDonald's India
actually changed Indian farming practices
just so they could grow the
kind of potato that they wanted?
When they first launched in India in 1996,
McDonald's promised the government
that they would use products grown
and sourced right here in India.
But people who had eaten McDonald's abroad
realized that the fries
didn't taste quite the same.
The reason for this is
that Indian potatoes
were too small, round,
had way too much moisture
and sugar content.
And so the fries made out of
them were not long enough,
they didn't get crispy
enough, and they didn't have
that distinctive McDonald's oomph to them.
So, McDonald's partnered
with McCain Foods,
and they spent nine years
trying to perfect their potato.
They imported saplings
which had the perfect shape
and starch content that they needed.
They also chose Gujarat
as their farming location
for its climate, and they switched
from a flood irrigation
to a sprinkler system
to reduce moisture content and save water.
The result: bigger and
more starchy potatoes
that can be used to make
the McDonald's fries
that you know and love.
McDonald's in the US
mostly uses russet Burbank
or Shepody, "shep-a-tee," potatoes.
Potato me.
So, these are big enough that
the distinctive long fry,
yeah, look how long this is. Wow!
Known to be low moisture
and low sugar content.
This means they can
remain crispy when fried
and don't caramelize too fast,
so you can get a nice, even browning.
McDonald's in the US actually discloses
all of its ingredients,
so we can figure out a
few other differences.
In the US, for instance,
our mayonnaise contains egg yolk,
as does most American mayo.
Thanks to the FAQ page on
the McDonald's India website,
we found out that the
mayonnaise is eggless,
along with all of the other sauces
except for the tartar sauce.
When people describe things
as vegetarian here in India,
they typically mean it
doesn't contain egg.
Joe: From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Domino's in India and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in India, our Domino's
pizzas come in three sizes.
Our Domino's pizza comes in four sizes.
Nikhil: The small, 8
inches with four slices.
Joe: The small, 10-inch,
which is six slices.
The medium, 10 inches with six slices.
Joe: The medium, 12 inches,
which is eight slices.
And the large, 12 inches
with eight slices.
Joe: The large, 14-inch, which is,
I don't know, four, eight, nine,
16 slices, 'cause I don't
know why they cut it this way.
I didn't ask them to, so.
And the extra large,
16 inches, or six slices.
Unfortunately, our large margherita pizza
only comes in one crust option,
which is the hand-tossed.
You don't get it in pan
or in cheese burst or any other kind.
So I am going to weigh one slice
of large margherita hand-tossed pizza
to see how much it weighs.
93 grams.
And I will weigh a
slice of our hand-tossed
and our pan to compare the weight.
Please note that our mediums
are the same size as their larges.
That's pretty insane.
Yeah, I'm not surprised
by that at all, buddy.
Hand-tossed.
One random slice is
79 grams.
A slice of pan,
same surface size, we'll say,
but obviously a lot thicker,
like, way, I mean, come on.
Ha!
139 grams.
So that's a little less than double.
This is a large Domino's margherita pizza.
It's also known as a
plain or cheese in the US.
This is 12 inches long.
It costs 419 rupees, or $5.55
at current conversion rates.
So the total surface area of this pizza
is 729.7 centimeters squared,
which means it costs 0.76 cents
per square centimeter of this pizza.
Take our large 14-inch pizza,
which is $13.99, or 1,056 Indian rupee,
with an area of 993.1 squared centimeters.
Just like these slices are squared.
I totally did that on purpose.
That's 1.4 cents per square centimeter.
That means the Indian pizza is 45% cheaper
than the American version.
This is everything you'll get
on a menu at Domino's India
that you will not get in America.
Little skyscrapers.
You guys have actual skyscrapers.
We have Domino's-pizza-box skyscrapers.
Here's everything at the US Domino's
you can't get in India.
We have five --
that's 10.
We have five different crust options.
We have pan.
Then you have wheat thin crust,
cheese burst.
Is there supposed to be cheese in here?
Oh!
There is cheese in here, for sure.
Then we have hand-tossed,
and we have something
called new hand-tossed.
Maybe somebody else's hands
were used to make this one.
In the US, our Domino's
has five crust options.
This one right here, gluten-free.
But you can only get
that as a small pizza.
Next, over here, hand-tossed.
Over here, the much thicker pan.
That's medium only.
This guy in the middle
here is the crunchy thin,
which I just found out five seconds ago
they also cut in squares.
Didn't know that.
Last and certainly not least,
this is the Brooklyn style.
They're thin slices, but
you can only get this
as the large and the extra large.
Hell yeah, that looks so good.
Just by looking at them,
I can tell that the hand-tossed
is slightly thinner.
Mm.
New hand-tossed.
It's a little firmer as a crust.
I would opt for the
regular hand-tossed pizza.
Finally, just for fun,
the cheese burst.
That is such a guilty pleasure.
So, I thought this was cheese burst
in the sense that just the
outer ring of crust had cheese.
The entire pizza base is cheese burst.
All right, here is our
range of vegetarian pizzas.
Here in India, to keep with
the religious sentiments
of both Hindus and Muslims,
who are a majority in our country,
we avoid using beef and pork
in most fast-food restaurants.
But what that means is that we get
a lot of delicious vegetarian options.
No. 1, Mexican Green Wave.
I will say the colors on this pizza
definitely look like the Mexican flag.
Jalapeños, some tomatoes, onion, cheese.
Next up, we have veggie paradise.
Wow.
Imagine calling an
entire pizza a paradise.
Red peppers, capsicum,
olives, corn, and cheese.
You guys in the comments, let me know,
does this look like paradise to you?
I'm not in the comments,
but I'll tell you right now,
it absolutely does not.
It's funny. Their veggie paradise
is my pizza hell.
Next up, deluxe veggie.
Mushrooms, paneer, corn,
capsicum, and onion.
I typically don't like when
there's too much on my pizza,
but the things here really
complement each other.
Pretty good. But, again, there's
so much going on in this.
It's truly a deluxe pizza.
Next up, we have Peppy Paneer. How fun!
Red peppers, capsicum, and paneer.
If you are wondering what paneer is,
it's basically cottage cheese,
and we love our paneer.
OK, next up we have paneer makhani.
If you're wondering what makhani means,
it's a paneer version of butter chicken.
If you're wondering
what butter chicken is,
friend, you need a culinary education.
Hm.
Would I ever want paneer
makhani on a pizza?
Maybe not. I don't like it.
Next up, we have cheese and corn.
It's got cheese, it's got corn.
And finally, Indi paneer tandoori pizza.
Tandoor is basically an oven we use here.
It's cylindrical. We use
wood fire and coal in it
to sort of give the meat
and bread some char to it.
And Indi, well, this pizza has
just not hit mainstream yet.
Oh, that is spicy and a half.
If you can't take heat, avoid this one.
My favorite so far,
none of them. I will
order a non-veg pizza.
Wow, India has a lot
more vegetarian options
than we do, and good for them.
I personally don't want any of that.
We do have two of our own
exclusive veggie options.
This here is the Pacific veggie.
And over here we have
the spinach and feta.
I don't want to try either of these.
Do I have to?
It's wasting valuable
stomach space, you know?
Like, it's only so big.
All this awesome Domino's food here,
you think I want any of this
in my stomach? Who cares?
All right, fine.
What's it got, like, feta cheese on it?
This isn't so bad.
Nonvegetarian pizzas.
No. 1, we have the pepper barbecue.
Doesn't look like it has any vegetables,
just a bunch of chicken pieces
and with a nice smoky barbecue flavor.
But you can choose a pepper
barbecue chicken with onion.
That is a great combination.
Chicken sausage. Quite
sausage-y, for sure.
The next pizza is what I believe to be
the best pizza you can
order from Domino's India.
The Chicken Golden Delight.
What a delightful name.
This is one of the oldest
pizzas that's been there
on the Domino's India menu.
It's got nice sweet corn,
it's got some jalapeños in there,
and some delicious, delightful chicken.
Next, we have the Dominator,
which seems to have
every single meat-topping
option on the menu.
My God.
Consider me dominated.
I don't think he knows what that means.
Wow. We're learning a lot
about Nikhil today, aren't we?
Whatever you're into, my man.
And next we have chicken fiesta.
It's got some tandoori chicken pieces,
some capsicum, onion.
Nice, simple flavors.
You can't go wrong with this one.
And finally, Indi chicken tikka,
which is just the chicken version
of that paneer pizza I had.
And that one just burned my lips,
so steer clear of this one
if you can't handle spice,
but if you do, this is
the one you should get.
Actually, some of those look pretty good.
I'm very impressed.
Now, here in the US,
every pizza that has beef
on it is an exclusive.
And we also got some chicken ones.
Let's do this. I am starving.
All the way over here,
this is the ExtravaganZZa,
which looks to have
bunch of veggies,
mushrooms, and pepperoni.
Yeah.
This is the MeatZZa. That's
with two capital Z's.
I'm seeing pepperoni, ham,
sausage, possibly hamburger.
All the meats.
Hell, yeah. Let's go.
Mm.
I can maybe do one bite of that.
My neck's starting to sweat.
Next, we got the Hawaiian pizza.
Mm.
A-plus on this one. I f--- with this one.
Definitely. Very good.
Cali chicken bacon ranch.
And you see, it looks like
it has sun-dried tomatoes,
bacon, I'm assuming, and
chicken, white sauce.
Little flimsy guy. This
is the Brooklyn style,
so I don't know why it's California.
Oh, yeah.
That white sauce.
Buffalo chicken pizza.
I mean, they drizzled it on there, right?
You see that? It's just drizzled.
This one's surprisingly very good.
The ultimate pepperoni.
Not just any pepperoni pizza.
Oh, yeah.
It's covered in pepperoni.
"Ooh" is right!
Mm!
Oh, yeah, put me in a pepperoni coma.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, the deluxe.
Deluxe is just that,
little bit of everything.
Black olives, sausage,
peppers, ham, probably bacon.
You put black olives on anything,
it just tastes like black olives.
Ooh, Memphis barbecue.
I am pro barbecue sauce on pizza.
And it looks like they
got chicken here too.
Yeah. Onions.
Mm.
Yeah. Oh, man.
That barbecue sauce. That's really nice.
Wisconsin six cheese.
There's no way there's six cheeses here.
I don't think I can name six cheeses.
We have mozzarella, cheddar, Asiago,
does American count as cheese?
Did I say cheddar yet?
Blue, I don't know.
Next up, if all of those non-veg pizzas
aren't enough for you,
they have an entire section
called chicken lovers,
and they have these four pizzas
that look absolutely insane.
They're more topping
than pizza at this point.
This one is called the chicken five feast.
So they have chicken,
pepperoni, chicken tikka,
chicken meatballs.
There is so much going on over there.
I like it, but it feels
like a drug, a pizza drug.
Next up, we have the spicy double chicken.
It has two different types of chicken,
pepper chicken and tandoori chicken.
And I assume it will be spicy,
and I'm going to take
Domino's word for it.
And then we have Chicken Maximus,
which sounds like a Roman
emperor who was also a coward.
They have chicken sausage, chicken tikka,
just a lot of chicken.
Just a lot of chicken.
That's what this has.
Like, oh, my God, can I just weigh this?
It feels like a small baby.
I'm holding a small baby.
545 grams for a medium pizza.
And finally, we have what
appears to be the king
of all of these chicken-lover pizzas.
It's an Indo fusion max.
Sounds like, I don't know,
some sort of detergent.
But, dude, you can't even tell what,
like, what number of
ingredients is on this?
I can't even see the pizza at this point.
Oh, my God.
I feel like a new man.
You have to order this once in your life.
It gives me deep displeasure to announce
that Domino's India has decided to create
these monstrosities called pizza burgers.
Look at this. [knocking]
Is a burger supposed to make this noise?
In Bengaluru, where I'm from,
if something bad happens to you,
your friend will say you got a bun.
And this is the bun they're talking about.
They have three flavors, classic veg,
premium veg, and classic non-veg.
Ah! Oh, man!
No!
It's just veggies and
sauce. Is that cheese?
No! No, no, no, no, no.
[sighs]
You know what?
I thought this would be bad.
And it's worse.
It's much worse. It's not a burger.
Nothing about this is a
burger except for the bun.
This might be the worst thing I've eaten
on "Food Wars" so far.
OK. We did kind of the same thing,
only we call them sandwiches.
I've never gotten one of
these outside of "Food Wars."
I'm just going to pick
this one right here.
It looks like it is a chicken habanero.
Everyone want to get bummed out? Aw.
Philly cheesesteak.
Listen up, Philadelphia.
Domino's wants to make you guys proud.
Philadelphia, why are
you not rioting right now
at the Domino's
headquarters, wherever it is?
Because this is just insulting.
Oh, no.
Remember the Mediterranean veggie?
Here it is in sandwich form.
Oh, this one has banana peppers on it.
Ooh, here we go.
Chicken bacon ranch.
Love that combination.
Oh, no. Yuelei, look at this.
Look at this!
This is just too much.
This one I just labeled "sandwich."
I didn't know which one it was.
What the f---? Look at this. What is this?
Is this the Buffalo chicken?
No on this one, guys.
Buffalo, let us know in the chat
how insulted you are by this.
Both residents of Buffalo
and Buffalo the animals.
Uh, Italian.
They didn't skimp on the pepperoni,
I gotta give them credit for that one.
The chicken Parm sandwich.
Surprisingly bland.
They're not terrible, but, I mean,
why get this instead of pizza?
Continuing the list of
exclusive abominations,
we have a string of pastas,
but also pasta pizzas,
which look, um, fascinating.
Here in Domino's India,
we use fusilli pasta,
fusilli being the whole
helix DNA strand of pastas.
We have creamy tomato, veg, non-veg,
and we have Moroccan
spice, veg and non-veg.
And to accompany these
I'm sure delicious pastas,
we have pasta pizzas in the same flavors.
Wow, just really inventive
stuff going on over here.
This is the Moroccan spice
vegetarian pasta pizza.
Here we go.
Voice-over: They ask you how you are,
and you just have to say that you're fine
when you're not really fine.
It sent a shiver down my spine.
It's so bad.
How many different types
of carbs are in this?
My disappointment is immeasurable,
and my day is ruined.
OK, I'm going to try one
pasta just in case it's good.
Let's mix it up.
This one has some tomato sauce in it.
This is bad.
We here in the US have our pasta options
that come in penne noodles,
these type of noodle guys.
Is that a good shot of a penne noodle?
You can get it in pasta primavera,
chicken carbonara,
chicken Alfredo,
Italian sausage marinara.
Again, I don't know why
you're getting pasta
at a pizza place.
I like it just fine.
Is this the best pasta you
can get in your neighborhood?
Most certainly not.
Now on to chicken wings.
We have three flavors, tomato chili sauce,
peri-peri, and boneless peri-peri.
I'm going to try the peri-peri wings
just to see how they stack up.
They're all right.
They're just your standard,
run-of-the-mill chicken wings.
In a country full of millions of flavors,
I can't believe we're
still doing these same
standard flavors like
peri-peri, barbecue, and ranch.
Where is my chicken
65, my chicken mughlai,
my chicken ghee roast?
Oh, chicken ghee roast.
Domino's, if you do
chicken ghee roast wings,
I think you're going to
get a lot more people.
Wings in the US. We got them too.
Here's three flavors that
we have here in the US.
Honey barbecue, sweet mango
habanero, and garlic Parmesan.
Domino's, if you're watching,
you need to, effective immediately,
stop doing this.
I don't know who in
your organization said,
"You know what we should do?
Instead of tossing it in the sauce,
you know, how everyone
expects their wings to come,
we'll just put it on here and drizzle."
Look at this. Look at this mess.
Toss it. Toss the wings.
Toss it in the sauce.
That's how everyone does this,
how it's supposed to be done.
Next up, exclusive sides.
No. 1, cheese pops.
Tater tots, as you call them.
We have fries, and they're
crinkle-cut. That's unique.
Not a lot of restaurants
here in India do this.
They have been flavored with
a bunch of stuff, though, so.
I think they've used their oregano
and chili flakes over here.
They have here a veg parcel.
It's like a little puff
with the same paneer pieces over here.
Then they have what they call tacos.
There's a vegetarian version
with some simple veg cutlets,
and they have a nonvegetarian version with
[laughs] a slab of chicken.
I did not expect that.
I am speechless at the level
of quality these sides have
compared to the pizzas.
Then you have a chicken parcel.
And finally, they have
little meatballs of chicken
with peri-peri dust on top of them.
This is literally just one
of their pizza toppings
that they're selling as a side.
Yes, India has breadsticks
and stuff with cheesy bread,
but they don't have garlic ones.
We got those.
We also have these Parmesan twists.
Look at these twisty guys.
And for stuffed cheesy bread,
you can get it as spinach and feta
or bacon and jalapeño.
Dips. This, I don't know what,
they just were like,
"How can we give people
pizza without bread?"
Behold, this.
It is a dish of cheese and marinara sauce.
They're calling them dips.
Cheesy marinara.
And the five cheese. Come on.
Look at that. Look at that oil.
You see that right there?
Exclusive sauces at the US Domino's.
You know what that means.
Sauce talk.
Here, you can get these
exclusive sauces in the US.
Can't get them in India.
We got hot Buffalo, sweet mango habanero,
honey barbecue, ranch,
ooh, blue cheese, for the wings, right?
And garlic.
Yeah, it says ranch.
They gave us two ranches instead of
a ranch and a garlic.
And marinara.
They were generous with the marinara.
That's a big one.
We have two separate dips
over here in Domino's India.
We have a cheesy dip,
and we have a cheesy jalapeño dip.
Cheesy dip.
Ooh.
Oh, that tastes good. OK.
Cheesy jalapeño dip, really yum.
Something about this tastes spoiled.
Is this past its expiry date?
It tastes like curdled milk.
Go with the cheesy jalapeño dip, for sure.
It's time for desserts!
Dessert.
We just have one dessert
here in Domino's India,
but it's a banger.
This is a choco lava cake.
You heat it up, and boom,
gooey lava goodness.
Oh, wow.
This fixed everything that was wrong
with the menu of Domino's up until now.
Just eating this is so comforting.
I can feel those memories of the pasta
and the burger and that
ridiculousness that they served
slowly disappearing from my head,
like thoughts from Dumbledore's head
when he's near the pensieve.
Hey, India, check out
these desserts we got.
You can't have them.
Over here, we have a
marbled cookie brownie.
I'd go for a brownie. Right?
What the hell, dude? These are great.
Oh, my God.
It's cookie dough and brownie.
What a great idea!
These dips. I don't know who
in your organization
said, "Let's do dips,"
but you need to let that person go.
It's, like, chunky apple
sauce and cinnamon twists.
Now it's time for drinks.
Yet again, it's PepsiCo winning.
Over here, we have Pepsi,
we have 7Up, and Mirinda.
Unlike a lot of other restaurants,
Domino's is yet to switch
from plastic PET bottles
to something like cans or reusable cups.
Drinks you can get in the
US, can't get in India.
I almost said the UK.
Jesus. I'm cracking up.
Coke, diet Coke,
Fanta orange, the Doctor,
Sprite, Dasani water.
I'm taking the Dr. Pepper.
It's time for calories.
Our large hand-tossed margherita pizza
has 256.4 calories per slice.
So that means the full
pizza is 2,051.5 calories,
which is over twice your daily
recommended protein intake
and 172.5%
your daily sodium intake.
Yeesh!
Our large cheese pizza is 2,240 calories.
That's a 9.19% increase
from India's cheese pizza.
Look, I screwed up.
I needed a thin crust for the
crust section of this video,
and I just randomly made it this large.
Just understand that ...
maybe, Victoria, can you do me a favor
and take this pizza here
and just put it right there?
Like, can you just do
that in post, please?
Next up, one slice of a
large deluxe veg pizza
is 220.5 calories.
And so the entire pizza
is 1,764 calories.
This is our large Pacific
veggie veggie pizza,
and it is 310 calories per slice,
which makes the full pizza 2,480 calories.
That's a 40% calorie increase in the US.
And, oof, get a load of that sodium,
over 200% your daily amount.
At Domino's India, our
highest calorific pizza
is the chicken dominatrix.
Chicken Dominator!
The chicken Dominator,
dominating the calories, I guess.
One slice will cost you 399 calories,
and the entire pizza is a whopping
3,192 calories,
which is 159.6%
of your recommended daily intake.
Please steer clear from eating
an entire chicken Dominator.
Our US Domino's pizza with
the most calories is this,
the Cali chicken bacon ranch.
One XL Brooklyn slice
of this is 560 calories.
That makes the full pie 3,360 calories.
That's 168% your daily
recommended calorie amount.
It's worth it. It's delicious.
Go get a slice.
Tell 'em Joe from "Food Wars" sent you.
They'll have no idea what
you're talking about.
Joe: From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Subway in India and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Subway sandwiches in
India come in two sizes:
6 inches, 12 inches.
Subway in the US also has those two sizes,
6-inch and 12-inch.
Now, the website also
says there's a 4-inch sub
called a chhota sub, chhota meaning small,
but mysteriously, it is unavailable.
We called four outlets. Wasn't there.
And now we shall measure the 12-inch sub
to see if it actually is 12 inches.
Joe: Keeping them honest, right?
That's 12 inches.
All right, Subway.
I'm getting more than 12 inches here.
Subway has given me a 13-inch sub.
This is why I love Subway.
Fun doesn't stop there, 'cause in the US,
Subway also offers catering options.
First, you can get this, a platter,
which is five foot-long
subs cut into threes,
making a total of 15 pieces.
See? Boom, boom.
The discrepancies continue here in India.
The website says that we
too have a platter option,
but we called a bunch of stores,
no platter option.
And on top of that, in the US,
you can get a 3-foot-long party sub.
Gush!
We didn't get it this time.
Graphics, you can go ahead and put a
3-foot party sub right in front of me.
Thanks, guys.
OK, is my ex-girlfriend running
the Subway and their website?
Because it's full of lies.
They not only advertise a 3-foot sub,
but a 6-foot giant sub.
And surprise, surprise, we
called a couple of stores,
no 6-foot giant sub.
In fact, they said, "There
are barely any 6-foot humans
here in India, why would
there be a 6-foot sub?"
And I was like, "Yeah,
sorry, I am the idiot."
Hang up!
OK, I am a short king.
175 centimeters.
This is how much I measure.
Now, this is a 6-foot sub next to me.
Why would this be a thing?
It's taller than me.
Well, Joe is 6 feet tall, so,
I'll go ahead and [grunts].
So, if graphics go ahead
and make me a sandwich
in three, two, one.
You know, this is pretty comfortable.
Can we do the rest of the shoot like this?
Ah, this is pretty nice.
Here in India, Subway
has actually opted out
of using a lot of plastic,
which is why they only
stock these 330 ml cans,
which I am going to
measure just to make sure
we are not being fooled by PepsiCo.
Mm. Smells like my teeth decaying.
Yeah, looks about right, 330 ml.
Subway in the US, we're still
totally using plastic cups.
Small, medium, large,
and the large is supposed to be 40 ounces.
Why someone would want to
drink 40 ounces of something
that's not malt liquor in
one sitting is beyond me,
but if you want 40 ounces
of soda, good Lord,
Subway has you covered.
I, of course, am curious to see
if there actually is 40
ounces in this drink.
Full "Food Wars" transparency,
I did have to fill up
my own fountain drink.
Let's be honest.
Can we agree that if you
had to get your own drink,
fill it up to go, you would
probably get this much?
Now, keep in mind, the cap is recessed.
For everyone roasting me in the comments
for not filling it up enough,
like, you can only fill
this thing up so much.
Oh, my God, not even close.
You know, I'm even gonna, like,
get the condensation on the cup in there
just to even, like, help tip
the scales in their favor.
Right?
34?
6? You guys are ... [sighs].
Just say it's the 34-ounce
cup. Or 35 ounces.
We're still gonna get it.
Still gonna get it.
Shame on you.
I saw that John Oliver episode.
Terrible, Subway. Shame on you.
What you're doing with the franchisees,
and what you're doing
skimping on the sodas.
Here are all the Subway
menu items from India
that you won't find in the US.
Here's all the Subway menu items
from the US you won't find in India.
Obviously, Subway lets you
customize your sandwiches,
so we're not talking about
every single different combination.
We're just going on
what is on the menu now.
Let's begin.
It's glorious.
This feels like a Subway buffet,
and I get to pick whatever I want.
First of all, the aloo patty.
This is basically potato which
has been cut up into pieces
and then fried with breadcrumbs on top.
Mm.
This is not bad, but I think you can add
all the fancy sauces you
want into this thing,
nothing will beat a
humble Mumbai vada pav.
Corn and peas. That
looks like a lot of mayo.
I don't think I shall ever order this sub.
This is a local legend,
the hara bhara kebab sub.
This is the first thing
a vegetarian will order
at an Indian restaurant,
because it's this delicious mishmash
of spices, vegetables, and potato,
fried, tangy, delicious.
Next up, we have a Mexican patty.
I would like to extend an apology
to all my Mexican brethren watching
that their great culture has been reduced
to a patty of aloo and beans.
Paneer tikka, beautiful pieces
of cottage cheese, as you call it.
Is it weird for me to bite a Subway
right through the middle?
Would that upset you?
It's nice.
I wouldn't go with this
particular combination
of vegetables and sauces.
Also, I just want to point
out there are literally
three pieces of paneer in here.
When I used to go to Subway in college,
I would make sure that they
put in a lot of protein.
This is despicable.
Veg seekh kebab.
Seekh kebab, typically, is minced meat
that's sort of pressed onto
a skewer and then grilled.
But this is a veg version.
It has a lot of different
mixed vegetables and potato.
Mm!
That's pretty yummy.
I love the onions. The
sauce combination is great.
And the seekh kebab itself, lot of flavor.
Next up, we have the
vegetarian shammi kebab.
As you can see, they're
nice round little balls.
Shammi kebabs are from
Lucknow here in India.
They have a very crispy exterior
and a delicious
melt-in-your-mouth interior.
They're typically minced meat,
but this is a vegetarian version.
Let me try this.
Mm.
Oh!
Best one so far.
♪ I'm so full ♪
Next up, chatpata chana Subway.
What a fun name.
Chatpata means full of masala,
zingy flavor, really delicious.
Chana is lentils.
It looks kind of like a dirty diaper,
but I assure you this is going
to be absolutely delicious.
Oh, yeah.
That's pretty good.
Now we're on to the nonvegetarian subs,
starting with this one,
the Indian chicken tikka.
Looks pretty good.
I just took a mouthful, and
there was absolutely no chicken.
Every bite should have
a bit of everything.
Chicken kofta.
Kofta is basically meatballs,
and this is chicken-flavored.
You can see the meatballs right there.
Whoa, that's actually really good.
Whoever picked the sauces on this one,
this is the way.
Barbecue, sweet onion, bit of ranch,
a bit of mint mayo.
This is the best sub out of all of them.
I actually think it's
the combination of sauces
that makes the sub what it is.
It's leaking flavor.
Peri-peri chicken.
Ever since McDonald's
released peri-peri fries
here in India,
there has been a peri-peri
revolution over here.
A peri-perevolution, as I like to call it.
Lot of chicken, lot of
meat, not a lot of veggies.
What happened here?
Some olives would've been nice.
And finally, this
rejected Subway over here
is tandoori tofu, which I
refuse to eat on principle
because we also have paneer over here.
It looks pretty much the same,
and I'm sure it tastes great.
You know what I realized?
Subways opened up like this
don't really look all that
great on camera, do they?
Oh, my God.
This looks like somebody's organs.
US-exclusive sandwiches.
You know what they say?
Greatness is in the agency of others?
Well, I'm here to say
greatness is in the agency
of other sandwiches.
I've tried almost none of these.
Starting over down here,
we have something called the mozza meat.
Let's take a look at this, Yuelei.
Oh, I don't think I've
ever seen this before.
Look, they even got the little, like,
the fresh mutzarel.
Has what looks to be
all the Italian meats.
Oh, by the way, unless otherwise
important to the sandwich,
I got everything with
lettuce, tomato, and onion
and no sauce unless it
includes a sauce. So.
Some mercy on the people
who had to wake up
two hours earlier to
make these sandwiches.
It's just like, yeah, just put
the same junk on all of them.
Moving on.
Supreme meats.
Oh, yeah. This is up my alley.
Salami, the other salami,
ham. No turkey though, huh?
Is this capocollo? What
is this? Provolone cheese.
This is something that I
would probably get at Subway.
The Baja turkey avocado.
Gonna open it up for you here.
Turkey. Oh, yeah, hey, they were generous
with the avocado I think, right?
Going right in the middle.
No big deal.
Moving on.
Honey mustard rotisserie-style chicken.
Oh, yeah.
I like the flavor of that
better than the regular chicken.
The all-American club.
Ham, turkey, bacon.
The Baja chicken and bacon.
It was, like, weak.
Even the bacon doesn't
have a lot of flavor.
Let's get into the steak.
Baja steak and Jack cheese.
Black Forest ham.
Buffalo chicken.
Oh, yeah, look at that.
Wow, they were generous
with the Buffalo sauce.
Chicken bacon ranch.
What does it say if the
strongest flavor in this
is the tomatoes?
You guys don't have the cold-cut combo?
That looks like bologna.
Then we have this next one.
Whoa!
The meatball, right?
India, I assure you, this
tastes way better than it looks.
Roast beef is, you guessed it, roast --
oh, God, that turned the
bread pink. Is that normal?
Ooh, spicy Italian. A favorite of mine.
Two salamis, both spicy.
You know, just like in Italy.
The turkey Cali fresh.
I think when something's a Cali sandwich,
the Cali means bacon and avocado.
The steak Cali fresh,
which has, let me guess,
bacon and avocado?
No.
Ah, there's the bacon.
So, unless I got COVID
in the past five minutes,
the food at Subway has seemingly
become incredibly bland.
Steak and cheese.
[laughs] These steak
sandwiches are like bricks.
Look at this. Oh, Yuelei!
Yeesh.
Now, there are some sandwiches
which appear on both menus
but have little differences
when it comes to ingredients.
For instance, our Subway
club comes with turkey,
ham, and bacon, and our
Italian BMT has ham.
In India, our Subway club
actually has turkey, lamb,
and chicken slices, and our
BMT does not contain bacon.
This is because most
fast-food outlets here
don't serve ham or beef
because it'll hurt the
religious sentiments
of Hindus and Muslims.
In addition to our sandwich fillings,
we also have some differences
in our bread options.
We have honey oat multigrain,
we have roasted garlic,
and Parmesan oregano Italian white bread,
but this looks oddly similar
to the American Italian cheese and herbs.
Is it the same thing, Joe?
Let me know.
No.
Here's the exclusive US
bread options at Subway.
Cheddar jalapeño bread, gluten-free bread,
tomato basil wrap, and hero bread.
In both the US and India,
you can get any sandwich
as a wrap or in a salad bowl.
Other US-exclusive option is the melt.
I wasn't going to get every single melt.
The list goes as follows.
Baja chicken and bacon melt,
chicken and bacon ranch melt,
Baja steak and Jack melt,
Buffalo chicken melt,
ham and cheese melt, Italian BMT melt,
meatball marinara melt,
oven-roasted turkey melt,
spiced Italian melt, steak and
cheese melt, and tuna melt.
I went ahead and got two,
steak melt, and, which one is --
oh, brother, the tuna melt.
Oh, God. It looks like cat food.
[whimpers]
All right, I definitely don't have COVID,
'cause I tasted that.
I need a steak-and-cheese-melt
palate cleanser after that.
Uh-huh. Mm!
Now we're talking.
Here are our breakfast-sandwich options.
We have egg and cheese,
chicken slice, egg, and cheese,
and Western egg and cheese.
I am very curious to know
what makes this Western.
Mm.
I can see how this would
be a Western option.
Nice, bland, easy on the palate.
Let me tell you something
about India, all right?
If you flavor something that we are buying
at a restaurant with just salt and pepper,
we call that a rip-off.
At least 10 spices.
For some inconceivable reason,
you can get their breakfast sandwiches
foot-long flatbreads.
Oh, good God. This, and they're so greasy.
[groans]
Egg and cheese.
Oh, look how terrible this looks.
[laughs] Ah, oh, no!
Where's the cheese? And, what?
Oh, come on, man.
Absolutely not.
This really is a bummer.
Oh, my God.
[squelching]
Oh, did you hear that?
I mean, these eggs, are
you kidding me with this?
What?
I couldn't imagine eating a
whole one of these for breakfast
without going directly back to bed.
There's a Black Forest
ham, egg, and cheese.
Oh, God.
And now let's never speak of
those breakfasts ever again.
We have some exclusive
Subway toppings here
in the US you cannot get
in India, such as spinach,
banana peppers [groans],
and Monterey cheddar cheese.
According to the Subway website,
in certain parts of the country
you can also get avocado,
carrot, guacamole, sweet
peppers, feta cheese,
Pepper Jack cheese, provolone
cheese, Swiss cheese.
Here in India, unfortunately,
all the toppings we have are
also available in the US.
Dammit, Subway. Are we not special enough?
Guys, let Subway know in the comments
what special toppings we
should have here in India.
However, we do have our
own exclusive sauces.
Sauce talk.
Starting with mint mayo,
which is absolutely a banger,
and the entire world needs to taste this.
Tandoori mayo, which we end up using
because we overuse the mint mayo.
This balances it out.
And, finally, red chili sauce.
I've also never heard of mint mayonnaise,
and that sounds incredible, actually.
So, in the US, we have a few
of our own exclusive sauces,
such as ranch, oil,
Subway vinaigrette, and plain mustard.
You guys have honey mustard like us,
but not plain mustard.
And in certain locations
around the country
you can also get Buffalo
sauce, creamy Italian sauce,
golden Italian sauce,
savory Caesar, Sriracha,
and, uh-oh.
Taziki cucumber.
[buzzer rings]
Taziki, or just, is the T silent? Ziki.
Tzatziki cucumber.
In my defense, I am incredibly nauseous.
What if we took all of
the US-exclusive items
and put them in one sandwich?
Well, this time we're not
going to, and thank you.
We actually made an effort
to make an edible US-only sandwich.
What we have is a steak
sub, cheddar jalapeño bread,
with spinach, banana peppers,
Monterey Jack cheese,
ranch, and mustard.
Hm.
This all works well together,
except the mustard stands out,
which is kind of a, mm,
could do without it.
And the spinach is fine.
I don't taste the spinach.
Guess it wouldn't kill me
to get some green in here.
Now, what about an India-only sub?
Here is one with the roast garlic bread,
tandoori chicken tikka,
mint mayo, tandoori mayo,
and red chili sauce.
Mm.
I'm really feeling the lack
of exclusive toppings here, Subway.
This is just meat dripping in sauce.
Make India-exclusive toppings
happen right now, Subway.
This is the "Eat Pray
Love" version of a sub,
in the sense that it makes sense
to everybody else in the
world except Indians.
Moving away from subs, our
snack section will tell you
that we have a pepperoni
toastie and a veggie toastie.
Unfortunately, at the
time that we ordered,
it was not available.
I have tasted them before, though,
and the pepperoni one is pretty yummy.
Subway has potato chips, of course,
and these are some US
exclusives, starting on this end.
SunChips cheddar harvest.
SunChips and Subway have always
had a really good alliance.
Good for them.
My favorite, Miss Vickie's.
The jalapeño chips.
These things are so good.
You can also get the Miss Vickie's
lime and cracked pepper chips.
The one I went to didn't have them.
This I can't believe.
You guys don't have the
nacho cheese Doritos?
I mean, this is, like, the
most popular chip, right?
And last, Lay's baked.
And also, kids can get
a pouch of applesauce.
I'm assuming adults can get it too,
but they're technically for kids.
In India, Subway's chip
options are a lot more limited,
and they vary from store to store.
The one we visited had
a variety of flavors
in Cornitos, which are basically
nacho chips, and Lay's.
And they had my personal
favorite Lay's flavor,
West Indies hot and chili.
But the crew has informed me
that they will not roll further
if I don't give a shout-out
to India's Magic Masala.
Our Subway cookies have
one exclusive flavor,
and that is this, the
raspberry cheesecake.
This is so good.
I don't know how they do it.
We sort of have an
exclusive here in India.
In the US, you can get
a chocolate chip cookie,
but here you can get dark
chocolate chunk cookie,
or, if you really want
to join the dark side,
a double dark chocolate cookie.
Here at the Subway in the US,
Coca-Cola rules everything around me.
We got a lot of Coke products here.
I put these in order of
which one I would probably
want to have with a sandwich.
Coke.
Diet Coke. Not a big
diet guy, but it's like,
eh, with the calories.
Next is Sprite.
I mean, who doesn't love
Sprite? It's a little strong.
I don't know if it goes well
with a sandwich, but why not?
Then we move on to the Simply drinks.
You got yourself Simply lemonade.
Who doesn't like lemonade, right?
Simply orange juice. I
feel like this is more
for the breakfast sandwiches, right?
I mean, OJ after 11 a.m.
seems kind of strange to me.
And then this apple juice.
If you want to have an energy
drink with your sandwich,
Vitaminwater XXX.
And then Gatorade. Gatorade?
Yeah, I mean, I like Gatorade, but,
I mean, it doesn't pair with food at all.
Last but not least,
all-natural-energy green tea,
hydrated coconut water, antioxidants,
electrolytes, with ribose.
Let's find out.
Whoa, that's terrible.
This one smells like BO.
Here in India, Subway's
actually partnered with PepsiCo.
So instead of Coca-Cola products,
you can get things like Pepsi,
Mountain Dew, Pepsi Black,
Mirinda, Tropicana orange juice,
and Aquavista water.
"From the makers of Aquafina."
That's so complicated. Why?
It's like a movie title at this point.
Which country is getting
a better deal on its subs?
Let's compare a foot-long
turkey sub in both.
In the US, this will cost you $8.99.
In India, ordering a
foot-long turkey club sandwich
on Zomato, one of our food-delivery apps,
will cost you 476.19 rupees.
That's around $6.27 right now.
And while that's 30%
cheaper than the US sub,
it's still pretty expensive
for the average Indian.
For context, in under $7,
you can feed an entire family of four,
and you're going to get a
very delicious, hearty meal
in most restaurants over here.
Now, to play devil's advocate,
the Subway near my college back in the day
had a crazy deal going on
where they gave us a 6-inch sub, a cookie,
and a drink of our choice in under $2,
and we used to eat lunch
there nearly every single day.
So, I guess, from store to store
there are different offers,
and Subway is and can
be kind of affordable.
Subway prices have been
a contentious issue
in America for a long time.
A franchisee named Stuart
Frankel invented the $5 foot-long
back in 2003, which hit
the mainstream in 2008.
Cheaper labor and food costs
combined with an increase
in foot traffic meant the
promotion was actually
a huge earner for Subway.
Sadly, it didn't last,
and the deal was phased out around 2012.
When Subway tried to
bring it back in 2017,
it was met with uproar
from many franchisees
who said it was impossible
to make a profit from the promotion.
The same thing happened again in 2020
when Subway tried to push a
$10-for-two-foot-longs deal,
which was killed after two weeks.
Which country's Subway
is the most unhealthy?
Let's start with a foot-long turkey sub
on whole-grain bread with lettuce,
tomato, onion, peppers, and cucumbers.
In the US, this sandwich
contains 520 calories,
6 grams of total fat, 2
grams of saturated fat,
78 grams of carbs, of which 12 are sugars,
and 1,580 milligrams of sodium.
In India, the nutritional information
for this same sandwich is 586 calories,
6 grams of total fat, 4
grams of saturated fat,
94 grams of carbs, of
which 8 grams are sugars,
and 1,362 milligrams of sodium.
When you break food down like
this, it sounds pretty scary.
So, the US sandwich has more sugar
and more sodium than the Indian version,
but they have the same total fat content.
I don't know what to take from that.
But the Indian version has
more calories, saturated fats,
and carbohydrates than the US version.
My theory is because we
have that extra inch.
What's the most calorific
thing on the US menu?
Currently, it's a foot-long
Cali fresh steak sub
with smashed avocado.
On whole Italian bread,
one of these is a hefty 1,220 calories.
There is also 68 grams of fat in there,
87% of your daily allowance,
as well as 2,380 milligrams of sodium,
over 100% of your daily allowance.
The most calorific thing
on the Indian Subway menu
is this: paneer tikka sub,
foot-long, whole-wheat
bread with standard salad.
It's a whopping 820 calories.
Now, this is less calorific
than the American Cali steak sub
and contains significantly less fat,
at just 41% of your
recommended daily intake.
The main thing to watch out for, however,
is the saturated fat.
There's 16 grams of it in here,
which is 80% of your
recommended daily intake.
Oh, saturated fats, you sly dog.
Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in India and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Burger King India, our drinks
come in one standard size,
which looks to be your small or medium,
but you can also opt for a can of 330 ml.
Burger King in the US, our
drinks come in four sizes.
Value, small,
medium, and large.
Let's measure this cup to see
how much is actually in here.
Does this make anybody else want to pee,
or is it just me?
Joe: 34 ounces.
Well, it says 38 at the bottom of the cup.
It ain't 38.
Our Burger King fries come in two sizes,
medium and king.
[angelic singing]
Our fries come in four sizes.
Value, small,
medium, large.
I remember the large
being bigger than this.
I'm just glad that the fuss we rose
for the first UK-US
"Food Wars" Burger King
has resulted fry transparency.
Next up, chicken fries.
I didn't know this was a thing,
so I'm very excited to eat them.
It should have five pieces.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six!
Thank you, Burger King!
Oh, never mind.
One of the fries had
broken. They gave me five.
Ours also is one size. Nine chicken fries.
It's like a pack of chicken cigarettes.
Seven, eight, nine.
A nice brown on brown.
Yeah. We thought ahead for this one.
Next one we shoot, I'm wearing all brown.
I'm wearing a brown jumpsuit.
We're gonna paint this brown.
The most unwatchable series.
Here's everything you'll find on the menu
at Burger King India that
you won't find in the US.
And here's everything you
can get at a US Burger King
you can't get in India.
Let's begin with the Whoppers!
This is a good time to
mention that here in India,
most fast-food restaurants
do not serve beef or pork
to keep the religious sentiments
of both Hindus and Muslims.
Conservative Hindus will not
enter a restaurant that serves beef.
Conservative Muslims might not
enter a restaurant that serves pork.
All right. Keeping all of that in mind,
let us begin with the chicken Whopper.
Whoo, boy!
OK, Burger King definitely
has larger burgers
than most other restaurants here in India.
Look at this. It's the size of my face.
I am the Burger King.
That's so good.
You might notice if you are a regular
Burger King consumer of the foreign lands
that if you were to eat this one,
it's a little spicier.
And I think they've done that
because most Indians love their spice.
There's a lot of bite to it.
Next up, double chicken patty.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
This one's got some heft to it, huh?
The mutton Whopper.
Mutton, if you are unaware, is goat meat,
and Burger King is one of
the few fast-food chains here
that actually serves
red meat of some kind.
Indians love their mutton.
I love my mutton.
It's definitely more meaty.
Has a lot more bite to
it than the chicken.
God, Burger King, what are you doing?
The quality is out of control.
Every beef burger at Burger
King is a US exclusive.
Got all the Whoppers.
Let's start down here.
The little guy, the Whopper Jr.
Not enough meat, you say?
You can get yourself a double Whopper.
Same burger, two patties.
Can they go bigger? They can.
The triple Whopper.
Look at this thing.
Hey.
Close your mouth when
you're taking a picture.
The Texans of the audience
might have to help us
out in the comments here.
The Texas double Whopper.
Texas prides itself, from what I can tell,
on always going bigger.
So why wouldn't it be
the Texas triple Whopper?
A rare moment where Texas was reserved.
Texans of the internet,
I think you guys need to step in here.
I don't think that sandwich
is doing you guys proud.
On to the veg options.
This is a veg Whopper.
I expect great things from this bad boy.
I would say this is pretty lackluster.
Next up, veggie double burger,
if you want double the disappointment.
Another thing that we have
that technically isn't beef
is the Impossible Whopper,
which is made with Impossible beef.
I'm actually very curious,
how does the Impossible
burger patty taste, Joe?
Regular beef.
I have to hand it to them.
It tastes exactly the same.
If you want to give the
environment a break,
maybe get one of these
every once in a while.
Next up, we have an exclusive
King collection of burgers.
These better be quite
royal and aristocratic.
No. 1, Hot 'n' Cheezy veg.
Lot of jalapeños.
The patty actually has,
like, cheese melt in it.
Hot 'n' Cheezy Kings collection,
on a scale of common
villager to the king himself,
I would rate this village bard.
Once in a while
you want him there just
to appease a few people,
but otherwise pretty lackluster.
Paneer Royale.
Just by the name itself,
this one should be incredible.
So, paneer, if you don't
know, is cottage cheese,
and here in India, it is almost a staple.
We eat it in everything.
We eat it in curries.
We sometimes just sear
it and eat it plain.
And obviously it had to
make its way to burgers.
The paneer is really
good. Chewy and delicious.
I would rate the Paneer Royale
a local baron.
Helps the king around a little bit.
Now on to the two non-veg
options. We have fiery chicken.
Plain and simple.
They just want this meat to blow my mind.
It's just spicy. That's all it is.
It doesn't have the depth of flavor
that the chicken Whoppers did.
Chicken tandoori.
If you guys don't know what a tandoor is,
it's basically this cylindrical oven
that we heat up using wood fire
and charcoal traditionally,
and we use it to create
everything from kebabs to breads.
I doubt all Burger King outlets
have an actual tandoor
in their restaurants,
but let's see if they were able
to replicate that smoky flavor.
On a scale of absolute
street urchins to maharajas,
I would rate these two court traitors
that tried to backstab the
king, and now they're on trial.
They have a lot of bark
but not enough bite.
They're gonna be executed.
Non-Whopper burgers, aka burgers.
You can get yourself
something called the Big King.
And that's what it looks
like. Don't have it.
What we do have is the
single quarter-pound King.
Bacon King!
I would say generous amount of bacon.
It's great.
Then these little, much more
reasonable-size burgers.
Bacon cheeseburger.
Bacon double cheeseburger.
A bacon-free double cheeseburger, right?
One of the most hilarious
things on the Burger King menu
is, of course, the Rodeo burger,
a burger with barbecue
sauce and onion rings,
because why not?
Then you got cheeseburger.
Regular dry-ass hamburger.
Who cares?
Enough kingly sandwiches.
It's now time for the regular
vegetarian options that they have.
We have crispy veg.
Crispy veg double.
Crispy veg with cheese.
BK classic.
BK classic with cheese.
Lite Whopper Jr.
And Lite Whopper Jr. with cheese.
Why is it called Lite Whopper Jr.?
How many more things do
you need to add to the name
to make it seem small?
Mini lite small Whopper
junior kindergartner burger.
How about that next time, Burger King?
OK, I don't want to try
any more veg burgers,
but this one, the BK classic
veg, seems different.
Like, the bun looks to be the same,
but they've definitely
used more perky buns here.
Don't use that audio clip out of context.
OK. Finally.
If you're a vegetarian,
I would recommend the
BK classic with cheese.
Boom.
Although it is currently
for a limited time,
I thought I would share with
you guys, here in the US,
we have the Southwest
options at Burger King,
starting with the Southwest bacon Jr.
Southwest Whopper.
The Southwest Impossible Whopper.
What makes a Southwest?
Ooh, I'm seeing, like,
crispy little chippy guys.
Ooh, spicy. Ooh, it's got some heat to it.
Yeah, there's guacamole on here. Hang on.
I kinda fuck with it.
I wouldn't eat if I didn't
work at "Food Wars," you know?
And now for the chicken sandwiches.
These look so tiny
compared to the Whoppers.
We have crispy chicken.
Crispy chicken double.
Crispy chicken with cheese.
BK classic chicken.
Spicy grill chicken.
Big smoky grill chicken.
Lite Whopper chicken Jr.
Lite Whopper double chicken Jr.
And Lite Whopper chicken Jr. with cheese.
Yes! I could work at
Burger King right now.
We're going to try just
two of these burgers
just to see if they're any different.
First one, the spicy grill chicken.
Oh, my God.
I can imagine myself
going to a drive-through,
taking one of these, driving to work,
sitting in Silk Board traffic,
getting annoyed with all
the other people honking,
realizing I should have
gotten a bigger burger,
and next day, ordering two. Nice.
Next up, the big smoky grill chicken.
I don't see how this is smoky at all.
In fact, it's kind of sweet.
On to the non-beef options.
I personally think these
new Ch'King sandwiches
are fantastic.
The Ch'King,
that's C-H-apostrophe-King,
because it's Burger King.
Spicy Ch'King sandwich. Same thing.
Got some spicy sauce on
it. This is very good.
If you like these but
want a little more veggies
because you're some old fogy,
here you go, vegetables.
They also make the Ch'King deluxe.
Deluxe equals lettuce and tomato.
This car crash of a
sandwich is the spicy ...
actually, the spicy with veggies
is actually kind of nice.
The coolness of the lettuce
and the tomato actually
counterbalances the spice.
The original chicken sandwich,
shaped like the new iPhone
for some strange reason.
This guy's been around forever.
It's their answer to the McChicken.
It tastes exactly like a McChicken.
Chicken Jr. Look at this little guy.
A spicy chicken Jr.
And last, the only non-chicken
thing in the chicken section
is the big fish.
And now for a set of snacks
that comes under their Stunner menu.
[whistling]
We have King egg burger.
King egg wrap.
Crispy veg wrap.
Veg crunchy volcano.
That's right. This is not even a wrap.
This is a little geological formation.
Tikki Twist burger.
Veg makhani burger.
And chicken makhani burger.
And finally, crispy chicken wrap
and crunch chicken volcano.
All right, the first burger we're trying
is the chicken makhani burger.
So, makhan means butter,
and it also means a lot to us Indians.
You just walk into a room
and you say "makhan,"
it will resound through the room.
Like, people's eyes will perk up.
The hairs on their arms will rise.
Oh, my God, yeah ... mm.
OK, so they've gone for, like,
a butter chicken, more makhani flavor,
but it just tastes like tomato puree
over a stale chicken patty.
Next thing that I really want
to try is the volcano itself.
And I think this is their answer
to Taco Bell's Crunchwrap.
Oh, that's pretty good.
You were this close to
offending two communities
and Mother Earth herself, but pretty good.
Next thing I'm going to
try is an Aloo Tikki Twist.
Tikki Twist sounds like a cocktail,
but aloo tikki is actually,
it's like mashed potato
fried with breadcrumbs,
and it's used in chaats.
It's used in a lot of other dishes.
And they put these crispy
shards of what seems to be
the same material in the volcano!
["The X-Files" music]
Illuminati confirmed.
On to breakfasts!
We got breakfast at the BK in the US.
You can get an assortment
of Croissan'wiches,
biscuits, melts.
I didn't get all of them.
Starting down here.
A Croissan'wich, of course, for
those of you not in America,
is they took a croissant
and stuffed eggs and cheese
and your choice of breakfast meat.
Bacon, egg, and cheese croissant.
Sausage, egg, and cheese croissant.
Ham, egg, and cheese croissant.
Bacon, egg, and cheese biscuit.
Sausage, egg, and cheese biscuit.
Ham, egg, and cheese biscuit.
Cheesy ham breakfast melt.
Sausage and cheese breakfast melt.
Cheesy bacon breakfast melt.
And for both the Croissan'wiches
and the biscuits,
you can also get pretty
much every combination
of meat, egg, and cheese on
said biscuit or Croissan'wich.
Egg-normous burrito.
Ah, no, no, no, no, no.
I am not starting off my morning
with this. No, thank you.
This looks like a dirty diaper.
Like, what is any of this?
I feel like if I bit this,
like, one bite of this in the morning,
and I'm on the toilet.
Get yourself two platters.
Sausage and pancakes platter.
And this one, I think, is,
like, the platter deluxe.
You get yourself pancakes,
get yourself bacon,
get yourself eggs,
and, of course, syrup.
Next up, chicken wings.
Burger King here sells
boneless chicken wings.
They feel like chicken tenders.
They're super meaty.
It's like proper chicken.
It's not like that processed, nuggety
chicken-juice thing that happens.
In the US, our Burger King has nuggets,
and they come in four
pieces and eight pieces.
I asked the Burger King
employees about the 16-piece,
and they said they don't have a 16-piece.
They just give you two eight-pieces.
Now it's time for Burger
King India sides and sauces.
No. 1, we have the
classic peri-peri fries.
They give it to you with a little sachet
of the peri-peri powder
and a little shake bag.
Pour it in there.
Voilà! Your simple plain
fries are now peri-peried.
Hm.
Go with McDonald's peri-peri fries.
I'm sorry, Burger King.
Too powdery. Almost chalky.
And the flavor is not quite there.
[coughs]
OK.
Peri-peri fries has come
back with a vengeance.
Fair enough. There is
a bit of spice to it.
Next up, cheesy fries.
Italian cheesy fries.
And I don't know what makes these Italian,
but I think it's a whole lot of oregano.
And finally, veggie strips.
Well, at the BK here in the US,
you can get yourself onion rings.
Jalapeño cheddar bites.
See what one of these looks like.
Mozzarella stick.
Mott's applesauce.
Can't have nuggets without sauces!
You know what that means!
Sauce talk.
As for the dips, we have Easy Cheesy.
Twisted mustard.
Fiery Hell.
They literally named one
of their dips Fiery Hell.
First up, Buffalo sauce.
Honey mustard. Ranch.
Sweet and sour.
Zesty sauce?
Do we know what this is?
That is just mayonnaise
and, like, brown mustard.
Marinara sauce.
Salsa del Sol.
It is milkshake time.
Burger King has three flavors right now.
They have mango, berry
blast, and chocolate.
Guys, at the time of filming this,
it is currently mango
season here in India.
None of you have tasted a real mango
until you've tasted the king
of all mangoes, Alphonso,
available here.
Everywhere you go right now,
you're going to get a
delicious mango milkshake.
We also make something called aamras,
which is like a delicious mango juice
that we eat with puris and stuff.
Let's see if this compares
to fresh mango juice.
Oh, it's pretty good.
It's not too sweet.
It does kind of taste like
mango ice cream sort of mixed.
But I like it. I really like it.
Next up, berry blast.
Paper straws. Burger King, thank you.
The dolphins appreciate
it just as much as I do.
Whoa, I did not expect that flavor.
Here, we have something
called black currant ice cream
that's rampant in very demented families
that order the black currant ice cream.
I'm sorry to single out these
Indian families like this,
but this tastes like that.
I'm sensing a pattern here.
So it won't be a surprise to me
if the chocolate milkshake
also just tastes like
watered-down chocolate ice cream.
The mango one, I suppose
if it wasn't mango season,
you could go and get a mango milkshake,
but otherwise, go to any other fruit
or milkshake store in India,
get a nice thick mango
shake with actual mangoes.
Way better.
On to the cold drinks.
Let's start with the shakes.
Over here, we have a frozen Coke.
You can also get a
frozen Fanta wild cherry.
Sounds amazing. Our Burger
King did not have it.
First one is this, the Oreo shake.
Why is that so good?
It's like a shake made out
of the stuff in the middle.
Brilliant idea.
And you can also get chocolate Oreo shake.
No, it's not. This one's better.
But this one's very good.
Desserts!
I'm a sucker for desserts,
but why would you order
dessert from a fast-food place?
Unless I'm going to be proven wrong.
First up, they have chocolate mousse cup.
OK, it's got a little bit
of cake at the bottom.
Chocolate, chocolate,
chocolate at the top.
Chocolate chips on the top.
Too decadent. Very sweet.
Next up, they have a choco lava cup,
keeping in theme with their
random volcano-based food items.
And I'm sure this would
ooze out chocolate,
but you have to heat it first.
That is so sweet!
When would I eat this?
I'm trying to think of
when I would eat something this sweet.
Never.
We have three dessert exclusives.
The first one is this,
the Hershey's sundae pie.
Chocolate chip cookies.
A soft-serve cup or cone.
Where is it, Joe?
Well, it's roughly 100 degrees
here in Southern California,
and that thing would've melted into a soup
before we even got it to the studio.
Imagine either a
soft-serve ice cream cone,
or a melted soft-serve ice cream cone
would be more accurate.
As for cold drinks, we
have Pepsi; Mountain Dew;
Mirinda, which is an orange soda;
and iced tea.
All of these are under the
PepsiCo range of products.
And, of course, in India,
the Pepsi slogan is,
"Har Ghoont Mein Swag,"
which means, "Every
sip has a lot of swag."
And I have to live with this cringe
for the rest of my life now.
Here in the US,
we have obviously a
variety of exclusive drinks
you can't get in India.
Coke.
Dr. Pepper.
Diet Coke.
There it is. Barq's, baby.
Fanta orange.
I should say that at
least the BKs that I go to
here in sunny Southern California
has those Coke Freestyle machines, so.
You can also get yourself an orange juice.
It's really funny looking at orange juice
next to orange drink.
Like, look at the difference with it.
Orange juice. Orange drink.
Capri Sun apple juice.
Burger King iced coffee.
The BK café, which is, of course, coffee.
Milk.
Let's talk price.
A single Indian chicken Whopper
will cost you 199 rupees,
or 1.56 US dollars at
current conversion rates.
In the US, a Whopper costs $8.79,
or 668 Indian rupee.
That's around a 236% increase in price.
Make it a meal with medium
fries and a large drink,
and it'll cost you 383
rupees, or 5.03 US dollars.
Add a medium fry and a
medium drink to the order,
and that brings the price to $16.37,
or 1,246 Indian rupee.
Again, about a 225% increase.
Now upgrade to the large size,
and it's 407 rupees, or 5.35 US dollars.
Make it a large, $16.77,
or 1,276 Indian rupee.
That's a 214% increase.
200 rupees for a single burger
is actually very expensive.
And while fast food in the US
and other foreign countries
might seem like something
that the average person can easily afford,
here in India, this is expensive,
and only the upper-middle
class and the rich
can actually go out and
have a burger like this.
In fact, in Mumbai, where
we're filming this right now,
our most popular street food is vada pav,
which is like a potato burger,
and it costs just 15
rupees, which is $0.20.
It can fill you up.
Downgrade the cost. Upgrade the taste.
Get a vada pav.
To better illustrate the price difference,
let's compare the US large Whopper combo
to our combination of two Whoppers,
two crispy chicken sandwiches,
five-piece chicken strips,
king fries, and four drinks.
All of this still costs less,
at just 1,102 rupees,
or 14.45 US dollars.
We would have to add a
crispy veg with cheese
and a crispy chicken with cheese
to get around the same price.
But again, I have to
remind you that in $14,
an average family here in India
could eat at home for a week.
Calories time.
My favorite part of these
videos because I realize
how much I should not be eating this food.
Let's start off with a
crispy chicken sandwich
from Burger King.
Ahem. It has 430 calories.
And in the US,
our crispy chicken
sandwich is 670 calories.
Next up is one of Burger King India's
most popular burgers, the veg Whopper,
at 728 calories.
Imagine that. High calories, low taste.
We don't have that, but in the US,
our Burger King does have
the Impossible Whopper,
which contains 630 calories.
Next, let's compare the fries.
An average box of king-sized fries
will cost you 535 calories.
If I had to choose between these fries
and an hour of cycling,
that's very, like,
probably skip the cycling.
But this is still bad.
It's a lot of calories.
And in the US, a large
fry has 430 calories.
And now, for some reason
if you're really looking
to pack on those calories,
introducing Burger King India's
most calorific sandwich,
the masala veg Whopper,
at a total of 734 calories.
Damn!
The website of Burger King India also says
they sell a 15-piece
grilled chicken wings,
with a total of 1,256 calories.
But we called a bunch of
stores, it was unavailable,
and I think they discontinued it
because they did not want
to kill half the country.
Oh, yo!
Yeah.
This is definitely a block of calories.
And in the US BK,
our most calorific sandwich
is this, the Bacon King.
Just one of these bad
boys, 1,359 calories.
Oof!
God dammit.
Brown on brown on brown.
Brown on brown on brown!
Brown, brown, brown, brown, brown.
Hey, you got to hand it to
these fast-food companies, man.
They make this s--- look real appetizing
for what is literally
how many different shades of brown?